if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
big massive dumps
dumps dumps
dumps
big massive dumps dumps dumps
[Music]
big massive dumps
that it was massive dumbs that led him
to lose the election which is just dumps
[Music]
amounts of water when water rushes out
to sea
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to Once
dumps
[Music]
big massive dumps dumps
jumps jump jumps
what is going on here what is what is
going on here
what is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
past the election
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
Alex Jones is now very very upset with
me
after right there
smarter than you think she's better than
you and he's gonna beat you Pac-Man
never talked to the new world war
because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is gone ladies and
gentlemen
God is telling my children who not to be
it's hurt
what you asked for is now at the door
scratching so open the door prepare to
meet your destiny
that is a freaking prefer right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you
then he went Donald Trump Donald Trump I
love Donald Trump but no more dropped by
the drop boxes are just so bad no more
drop boxes Dickinson full logic and
cephe cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth essential
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama
amnesty as you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP Greg J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
suchin tendulker duviron Kohli as the
great religious teacher Swami Vive come
once said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infantryman badge for his service
we have to keep our country gay people
but it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
Law and Order look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
cycling and signing and the great
General and President Ulysses S Grant
he's done he's really come back a long
way over the last 10 years hasn't he
appreciate it very much Tim Apple when
they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they
delivered a Swift and Swift in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sleeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasma into
failing New York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business the teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children without
parent of himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you heard them and you know them well
mangoes
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now cost
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it I want what eight or eleven
bucks
[Music]
bring my mango
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
[Music]
s
well the time has come it is the fourth
and final day of CPAC with Deepak 2023
the failed former president Donald Trump
who is again saying pick me pick me in
2024 will be speaking to us in mere
moments scheduled for 25 past the hour
and it is so great to have everybody
here
um there has been a it's been a unique
CPAC in a few different ways and we are
now at the culmination of it in
Washington DC uh it's been unique in
that it has been particularly pathetic
because its organizer Matt schlapp
brutally accused of sexually assaulting
a male intern of Herschel Walker some
months ago
uh and that has certainly put a damper
on the entire thing
um additionally a lot of people turn
down invitations to CPAC for whatever
reason right and we could speculate as
to the reasons why
um and thirdly there is a republican
civil war going on and in fact the early
reports and as you can see this is very
serious mental illness that's taking
place at CPAC here very very uh really
um putting on the front page at the
Forefront of our minds the
um Mental Health crisis in the United
States
um the third element of it is that the
reports are that Trump is going to go
absolutely bazingas this evening on the
Republican party on the bush Republicans
the Rhino Republicans as he calls them
and
I would say that tonight is the official
start of the 2024 uh primary now I know
you might say well David sir you're
making me cry I'm a big tough guy you're
making me cry anyway because weeks ago
Nikki Haley announced that you know
she's a woman and she's younger and
she's Indian and vote for her uh in an
example of identity politics wasn't that
the star or wasn't the start when Trump
announced or won't the start be when
DeSantis announces I I believe tonight
the tone will be set that this is the
start of the 2024 Republican primary I
believe it is going to be by far by far
the ugliest the ugliest that
um I am ever going to cover
uh okay let's see what else we have here
um
okay a lot of strange anti-semitic
comments come it's a little early for
the anti-semitic comments I do want to
say but uh you know we can we can start
the bands socialism is when no fridge
has just signed up uh with the twitch
Prime subscription and I very very much
appreciate that as we are standing by
here and I guess Rush Limbaugh and
something else
um everybody's doing everybody's doing
different things but we are moments away
moments away from the Trump speech uh
okay super chats no no super chats yet
let's look at a few moments Oh by let's
actually let's look at polling so going
into tonight's speech with the idea that
this is really the official start
um of the 2024 Republican primary you
see that Trump is still polling very
strongly when it's Trump DeSantis and
Nikki Haley Trump is up 12. uh when it's
Trump Haley Trump is up 33 Trump
DeSantis Trump is up eight
and this is a different version I guess
oh this is with a whole bunch of
different people you've got a lot of
zeros Chris Christie polling zero uh
Trump is up 16. so listen it's it's very
early to say anything specific about the
value of these polls other than it's
better for Trump when there are more
candidates or candidates as some like to
say I say candidates but some people say
candidates
um the more people that are running the
better it seems to be for Donald Trump
so far so those are the circumstances
going into this thing
um we also have I guess we can look at a
few moments Mike pillow announced
something incredibly incredibly strong
at today's
um event over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines yeah listen to
what he announced RNC because I'm going
to do a call out to them if you all know
that Ronald McDaniel said that she'd
look forward to working with Mike
Lindell if you know well what do you
think if you're working with me what do
you think you're going to work on right
it's pretty obvious well we've we're I'm
announcing the putting everything under
one rope in this country everything that
all people across this country have been
doing different groups we've been trying
to keep it all oriented but by the way
he is shaking that lectern like crazy
it's very very odd yeah the election
crime bureau.com you can all check it
out I'm making the announcement here
whoa the electioncrime bureau.com
anybody know what's on that site when I
checked it earlier it gave me an error
okay he doesn't need any help but he's
asking just just for an endorsement and
an endorsement alone super chats coming
in Michael says did you hear the Donald
Trump song he did with the January 6
writers I did not
I did not megwine says love the show
David sir here's something so you can
share some mangoes with your family
thank you very much Meg very much
appreciate that we got to get those uh
we got to get those mangoes back down
that's for damn sure
um let's look at a couple other Crips
Clips Crips let's look at a few other
Clips here from um
CPAC as I like to call it
um here is
Steve Bannon wearing what looks like
hold on how many shirts is he wearing
one two three shirts
three pens and two phones uh a a
disturbing image
a disturbing image and I I really don't
know why he wears that many shirts
but that is a hell of a lot of shirts
folks hell of a lot of shirts let's see
what else happened today at CPAC
um
Sebastian Gorka dressed like Sean Penn
interesting
here's Elise stefanic you can always
count on her to bring sobriety and
common sense to any discussion
[Applause]
for files and the FBI's illegal
suppression of the hunter Biden laptop
story shamelessly use it anybody know
what crimes were committed there and by
the way
anybody have any idea what the crime was
when Twitter was like you can't post
naked pics of Hunter what what crime was
committed anybody know
millions of taxes it was fentan all
right yeah
Twitter to interfere in the 2020
election on behalf of Joe Biden right
it's Un-American and we will hold them
accountable
excellent so anyway we're standing by
for pretty major accountability Andrew
says with a beautiful Super Chat can we
get a trump audio glitch yeah let me see
if I have the Trump audio glitches
people were starting to come that's not
it that's the wrong one hold on is this
it man he's gonna represent you no
that's not it oh wait here further
scream that his days are numbered
that was one of them and then here are
the other Trump audio glitches
[Music]
divide
let me recover my ears for once I hope
it was a preview or I'm hoping that
there will be major major audio
malfunctions during Trump's speech
tonight welcome everybody it is still
early would you have not missed anything
yet
um well we're looking at Super chats and
hearing from people did I see where
Gates threatened to take Democrats off
committees if they don't get behind
their sham investigations no let's see
if we get to that in our highlights in a
moment
Sir with tears in my eyes nightbot got
me for spamming mangoes I'm guilty and I
Repent here's five dollars as tithings I
appreciate that
DJ Kento says as a fat guy I can tell
you why Steve Bannon wears so many
shirts it's to even out the lumps in
your body and make you look big but not
fat it never works wow uh hyper-specific
explanation from DJ Kento
Yours Truly the number one pony says sir
watch a doc about the painful history of
the Native American in early America you
know the kind of History Republicans
don't want you to know about right
right absolutely
um
okay
let's see what else we have here
oh I did want to dump in one quick
voicemail let me see if I've got it
I don't have I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to find it for for us for a little
bit later David Blaine says love the
show David how badly were you affected
by the 2019 adpocalypse specifically I
am not aware of any 2019 adpocalypse I
remember the 2017 adpocalypse and we
lost at that point 98 of our YouTube
Revenue
but 2019 adpocalypse I actually don't
remember if it was a minor if it was
like a little it wasn't an apocal it was
more like a Rapture a mini Rapture
um then I could I could you know look
into the details a little bit a little
bit more all right let's look at a
couple of other Clips here here oh my
God Michael Knowles spoke at CPAC and he
went on an anti-transgender rant
men
there can be no middle way in dealing
with transgenderism it is all or Not by
the way that's the type of tie I wore to
my parents New Year's Eve party when I
was seven years old and I wanted to
dress up in like a mini suit this is
that that is exactly the tie except mine
the the dark blue was like a slightly
lighter blue it's very interesting I
used to have that tie 30 years ago
if transgenderism is true if men really
can become women then it's true for
everybody of all ages you know the
really dumb thing you you guys all know
that
I know I don't have to do any of the
disclaimers you all know that I'm open
to saying we have to figure out what to
do with some sports and we should be
really clear about the long-term effects
of puberty blockers because there are
concerns about osteoporosis and bone
density like research absolutely
everything but these guys like to do
something slick which is they go
prove that men can be women it's like
wait a second wait a second wait a
second
if you want to talk about proof right
it is a fact
that people vary in their gender
expression it is a fact right whatever
you want to say and and Neil deGrasse
Tyson or Neil Tyson to Grass as many of
the people who email me about it say
Neil deGrasse Tyson in an interview with
Benjamin Shapiro
made this Crystal Clear which is like
listen you can talk about are there some
aspects of transgenderism that would be
for a biology class are there aspects of
transgenderism that would be for a
Sociology class or whatever but the the
one fact that we have here is
people Express their gender on a
spectrum
and given that that is an undeniable
fact now it's just a question of okay
how do we guide public policy around it
how do we guide all of these different
things
um but they they love this whole thing
about the the truth can can men really
be women well the the truth is there's a
spectrum of gender expression that's the
truth and it's an undeniable truth if
transgenderism is false as it is if men
really can't become women as they cannot
then it's false for everybody too
right and if it's false
then we should not indulge it
especially since that Indulgence
requires taking away the rights and
customs of so many people if it is false
then for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion trans why don't you help
actual poor people rather than supposed
victims of of someone else being trans
which is crazy gender must be eradicated
from public life entirely eradicate
transgenderism you guys heard that right
everybody's clear on the language there
the whole Preposterous ideology at every
level
nothing titillates a CPAC crowd like
homophobia or transphobia
so for people wondering like what the
hell is going on with Michael Knowles
I'll I'll do you guys want to know I
don't know if I'm allowed to say this
do people want to know what's really
going on with Michael Knowles
people don't want to know oh wait a
second is Trump here
oh let's see what this is cheering about
it for the first time about the loyalty
for probably people that I wouldn't be
very happy about endorsing you know
running so we'll see I think some of
them I won't use names I don't want to
insult any but but some of them I would
not be very happy about so we'll have to
think about that Mr President
machine
I think that uh we have lots of
opponents so we have lots of friends and
you see the Friends by the amount of
people here right now people are camping
out overnight they've been here for
three days I didn't even come in they
just wanted to see this particular
speech and I hope you're going to enjoy
it I don't think we have a lot of
opponents that are going to be effective
Mr President James Rosen with Newsmax I
have two questions about the election if
you'd indulge me
um this campaign for the presidency
unfolds against the backdrop in which
unlike the previous ones you face a
multiple criminal investigations into
your activities I know that you have
dismissed these as politically partisan
witch hunts and that you maintain your
complete and total innocence nonetheless
we are given to believe that one or more
of these investigations
May soon approach their resolution in
terms of the handing down of indictments
right good question
um can you take this moment to assure
your donors and your supporters that
you're in this race to stay no matter
what happens with those investigations
good questions sure indicted
to a phony impeachments and we won that
and the Republicans stuck together you
guys know Trump won the impeachments we
went up very substantially into Falls
these are witch hunts these have been
going on for a long time they've
weaponized Justice in our country it's a
disgrace and I think people are very
angry about it even Democrats are very
angry about it so you'll stay here oh
absolutely I wouldn't even think about
leaving these are
fake stories these are horrible the
Press is uh pressing Trump looks ill
something and it's I think it's very sad
for our country I think it's very
dangerous for our country and people I
can say that you have thousands of
people outside and you didn't have that
for others they're very upset and very
angry about it it's just a continuation
of the you're just joining us Donald
Trump is holding some kind of a
impromptu press conference uh before his
CPAC speech which is starting in about
10 minutes away from the justice
department or as I call it the Injustice
Department
it starts there Trump won two
impeachments but lost the Super Bowl
agencies and the local DA's and attorney
generals they put people from the
justice department in the Manhattan DA's
office I mean think about that uh
they're racists you get a lot of racists
you got a lot of race baiting it's a
disgraceful thing that's going on
there's no but the country's never seen
anything like it and yeah probably
anybody think Trump could Define
race-baiting in any way that anybody
would understand it
Mr President real quick let's talk about
your policy you just announced you'll be
in Iowa on March 13th to talk about your
America First education policy would you
care to elaborate on that well I'm gonna
have a very long statement on that and
we're going to be doing things that are
I think going to be very very beneficial
I was going to do it probably second
term and then we had a great election we
got 12 million more votes than we got
the first time we did much better than
we did the first time my second election
was so good that I ended up not being
president and unable to do any of this
stuff get that number you can't lose but
we were going to do this I would like to
just about end the Department of
Education it's time the country does
very well in some ways but very badly in
others fantastically in everything we
did as good as you can do in education
but you have to get rid of the
Department of Education close it up and
get rid of the list of countries we're
always at the bottom we spend more money
per pupil and we're always at the bottom
of the list we're terrible at math so
close the doe up and let local areas and
frankly States handle education I don't
know if that's good politically to say
or bad politically to say but that's the
way it's going to be we're going to
close it up thank you Mr President has
not entered this presidential race yet
but he appears to be your most
significant Challenger in a one-on-one
matchup a lot of the folks we talk to
out here say that they love to see a
trump DeSantis ticket what do you tell
them would you consider asking Rhonda
Sanchez right now to be your Vice
presidential pick beautiful well I've
always had a great relationship with Ron
I was the one that made it possible for
him to win he was at a very low number
and after I endorsed him he went up by a
lot and he asked me to do that I've
always had a good relationship with him
but it's much too early to talk about
why should he not be the presidential
candidate for Republicans well he can be
if he wants to be why should the folks
not turn to him if he makes the case of
being a new generation I think I've done
something that nobody else has been able
to do we turned around this country this
country was never better our economy is
the best in history it's actually pretty
interesting I have to say get rid of the
biggest regulation cut in history I mean
he's lying uncontrollably but it's
interesting things that nobody else has
done and you wouldn't have had Ukraine
and Russia fighting it would have not
happened zero chance of it happening now
as you know China is looking at Taiwan
and president XI who's somebody else
very well China never happened they
wouldn't be looking those bombers
started going over and taking pictures
of Taiwan the day I left and should have
never left because frankly that election
and people have to look at it they're
going to be looking at it for a long
time it was a disgrace it was a disgrace
to our country and I will say that all
of the things all of the great things we
did I don't think anybody else could
have come close to doing them and I
think for the most part we've been so
rewarded we've been rewarded with
tremendous adulation and it's not for me
it's for all of us it's for the
administration but it's for the people
make America great again we put America
First and nobody's been able to do that
he really martyred himself important in
a certain way we were respected like
never before absolutely no poll you can
find that shows we were more respected
under Trump you look at the fact that we
took out the Isis caliphate everyone
said that was impossible to do I did it
in three weeks now I think we have a
record that's really unsurpassed on
China do you feel Vindicated that even
the FBI which has been after you are
obviously uh is basically confirmed what
you said first that this this may have
been a Wuhan lab league and you're also
the only candidate that I know of who
has spoken aggressively about holding
China accountable if you're elected
again what will you do tough question to
make China pay for that well Ed I said
very early on this is Wuhan lab that's
where it came from and what will you do
in three years to hold China accountable
for something you almost certainly
completely misunderstood three years ago
you know that and it turned out to be
warhand love it is Warren live I don't
care what they say they say Department
of energy made a statement and some
other department made it that doesn't
matter I felt it was Wuhan lab that's
where it came from I also think they
made a horrible mistake somebody blew it
China what do you call it incompetence
or anything else because obviously and
you've seen it more so in the last year
than you did he is doing the thing where
he hinges forward and rocks it's a very
interesting thing it's almost like a
wooden doll it came from there yeah and
they should be in some way there should
be something paid to the world the world
lost 50 trillion dollars that's the way
I estimate 50 trillion dollars China
doesn't have 50 trillion dollars or
anything close right but something
should be done for the World by China
because what they put the world through
is a terrible
terms are you surprised that Joe Biden
still has not been to East Palestine you
went there you kind of shamed the
transportation secretary into going you
brought your own water he shaved the
same what oh shamed oh my god well I'm
surprised that he hasn't gone I think he
should go it shows Spirit it shows a
little Unity it was an area that voted
very much for Trump but that doesn't
really I go to areas that didn't
necessarily vote so much for me I think
he's making a big big mistake by not
going Mr President
Mr President Mr President thank you for
taking my question sir unlike the
current Administration when you're in
office you held Vladimir Putin in Czech
sir
taking the check well he knew there'd be
retribution if he wanted to Ukraine he
knew that he was told that very strongly
sure sure very good relationship with
him but he understood that and I said
just don't do it he wasn't going to do
it there was no this is beyond parody
well you know if you look at the border
forming and everything else with the
soldiers he did this after I was gone it
would have never happened it's one of
the saddest things because so much you
wouldn't have inflation you wouldn't
have a lot of different things but one
of the things you wouldn't have had is
Russia invading Ukraine and when I see
all of those tens of thousands of people
being killed on both sides tremendous
numbers of soldiers on both sides uh you
look at the destruction where cities are
Level to the ground there's no City left
I mean there's no a lot of these areas
are just gone take you 50 years to
rebuild them those beautiful buildings
those ancient buildings with the gold
this is almost better than the speech
guys I have to say it's a very very sad
thing it could have been and it would
have been very easy at the same time and
I'll be talking about in the speech I
could settle that situation in 24 hours
as president I could say just like he
was going to fix the israeli-palestinian
conflict in that first year of his
presidency just like that now people are
dying and it's only going to get worse
Ukraine is being blown up all of its
cities all of its places all of its
energy area they're all being blown
everything's being blown to smithereens
and it really has to have it now and by
the way Russia is taking big lumps also
in many different ways so poor Putin
have you seen the guy in 24 hours if
people knew what they were doing Mr
President Mr President uh Mike Pompeo
here yesterday
um talks about how the right shouldn't
follow celebrity leaders those whose
fragile egos who refuse to acknowledge
reality was he talking about you do you
have a response no I don't think he was
talking about me I don't consider myself
a celebrity leader I consider myself a
leader of the country and but I don't
consider myself a celebrity leader I
didn't do this celebrity uh maybe it
helped me get elected who knows but I
don't consider that I consider myself a
person that was President for four years
and we had record business record
employment we had the strongest economy
in history and I really did it twice
because we then got hit by the China
virus and I had to rebuild it again and
I gave over a stock market that was
higher than just before the virus China
China so uh no I don't think so I can't
imagine he was talking
should
vice president Harris in your view when
the electoral votes from the 2024
election are certified in the Congress
have the power when that's happening
to reject Republican electoral well you
know they did have a certain power they
certainly had the power to send it back
because right after everything was over
and they all said they didn't have it
and I said well our vice president isn't
supposed to be a conveyor belt if they
find something wrong they should do
something about it but the change as you
know the Voting Act they changed it
right after now I said why did you
change it if he couldn't do anything
they said well he could do something it
turned out that it was a big con job but
Crystal Clear answer about about the
constitutionality and procedure just
Crystal Clear Mr President you posted up
on Truth social or a really creative
picture about Nikki Haley and the empty
seats that were in their Arena and you
said hey follow your heart you want to
follow up on that post no no I mean I
hope she had a nice crowd but it didn't
look like it was very good but I liked
it she's uh got to follow her heart I
told her follow her heart
oh I'm not going to tell you that
because if I told you that secret
I probably wouldn't be able to do it
it's a secret guys you know we're
playing a giant chess game here we're
not just you know let's I'll tell you
exactly what I'll do it would be so easy
to settle that war yep I could do it in
24 hours but it's going to be a secret
guys please to do it you have to be
president you need that office that
power that whatever it is that would be
settled in 24 hours and again it never
would have happened it never I believe
it would have happened I believe not
even thinkable but that could be settled
in 24 hours and that's what should
happen and then that war should be
settled in 24 hours in the meanwhile
would you encourage Congress to continue
to provide Aid to Ukraine I would say
that Europe should start spending money
we're spending we're missing 40 billion
dollars and they're at like 50. so he he
doesn't really know the answers to these
things because it's like okay if he says
no more money for Ukraine that's weird
because it looks very Russia friendly
you're basically saying do whatever you
want Russia but so he comes up with
these things like well Europe should
spend more money because he doesn't
really know the answer he doesn't have
any idea saying for NATO you know that I
mean it just weren't paying and I got
them to put up
447 billion dollars in a very short
period of time they wouldn't have the
money to be fighting Russia right now
but wasn't for me but what I don't like
seeing is that the United States is in
for and and you hear a lot of different
calculations you hear a hundred you hear
90 or 114 you hear 140 today but we're
in for let's say 140 billion dollars and
they're in for less than 25.
and it affects them more so one of the
things I like is at least let's not be
called a stupid country
and that's what they call us because
we're defending that hole they called us
that when Trump became president
Germany's not paying a chair other
countries are not paying a chair and the
United States is really taking the whole
load and it's not right and you know you
could sit down with these other leaders
I know all of them or most of them and
within 10 minutes they would agree to
pay if you said the right things to them
but they're not paying we're paying and
that's unfair
Nikki Haley was in your Administration
and others who served under you are
potentially getting in the race as well
what sort of message does that maybe
send about you or their views of your
leadership well I really say the more
the merrier I mean they think they did a
good job
and I think now remember Trump says the
more the merrier for the primary because
the more people that are in the polling
the better Trump does the more the the
non-trump vote is split the better it is
for Trump that's why Trump wants a bunch
of people running actually I got rid of
them I'd say you're fired and get
somebody else but uh we agree when you
think of the economy we built when you
think that I rebuilt the military I
knocked out Isis I did so many different
things the military the cupboards were
bare when Trump came in
[Applause]
so here comes Trump we are going to
watch this live thank you to ghost
rooster for the twitch Prime
subscription and a huge thank you to
Juan Morales who just signed up on my
website folks we will watch the speech
if we are at a hundred website members
by the time it's over we'll open up
phone lines I want to hear your
reactions to what happens here this is
going to be a doozy that's for damn sure
and remember today's coupon code is CPAC
trash because that's what we're watching
CPAC trash is the coupon code you go to
joinpakman.com I'll see it pop up the
bar will fill up and then hopefully when
this is over we will uh we we will open
the phone lines and by the way if we get
to 250 I will shave half my mustache and
do the Monday show with only half a
mustache I kind of hope it doesn't
happen to be perfectly Frank it seems
like it would be a little embarrassing
for me but I'm willing to do it I'm
willing to do it this is going to be
very painful couple super chats David it
was the crime of wokism right that was
the crime that took place a buddy of
mine I served with in the Marines is ex
Maga he's from East Palestine we're both
watching your stream up here in
Cleveland give a shout out to Austin sir
Austin big shout out to you and Charlie
says Trump is likely to go off the rails
please have the mercy bandhammer yeah if
this becomes too much for some people we
can give out a mercy ban okay so just
ask the moderators and then we can ban
you just if it if it really if it
becomes too much but my preference would
be stick around
get a membership at joinpakman.com and
then call in and tell me how horrifying
it was when we opened the phone lines
um a little bit later okay
[Music]
and of course it's completely credible
that Trump you know rich guy from Queens
loves country music that's a completely
believable thing as all of you know
[Music]
Jody is uh sending a super chat for some
funds for earplugs yeah this this is
really going to be now it's Trump
expected to slam Republicans
[Applause]
thank you
and we will ban men
well thank you very much and I'm
thrilled to be back at CPAC with
thousands of great and true American
Patriots and that's what you are
I want to start by thanking Matt and
Mercedes schlapp and everyone at the no
mention of Matt being accused of
pummeling the junk of uh Herschel Walker
Aid that's strange full event it really
has been something over the years I also
wonder we have so many people here I'm
going to leave out some but they'll
understand we have a lot of Congress a
lot of Senate a lot of everything but
we'll do a few words and a few names
Diana harshbarger thank you Diana
congresswoman Mike Collins
[Applause]
she's a rocket
thank you Elise Jason Smith friend of
mine great guy
Wesley hunt
Corey Mills Dr Ronnie Jackson he's a
doctor he's an admiral whiz
he said I'm the healthiest man ever to
be president by far
said if I wouldn't need junk food I'd
live 200 years where is his sticker it
is
he had a lot of a lot of things under
his belt another one who's a serious
character but a great guy you got to
know him he's a great guy Matt Gates
thank you Matt great guy
He's a brave guy
and another Brave person she started off
very slow very very slow she she's a
low-key person Marjorie Taylor green
Audrey
location much Marjorie a friend of mine
a man who's terrific almost one for
governor of New York could have done it
but uh so many people have moved out of
New York it gets tougher but he's a
terrific guy great lawyer too and he's a
strong guy you know he stopped somebody
coming at him with a knife I don't know
he grabbed that guy's hand he looked
pretty tough and he drove him to the
ground Lee zeldon Wesley sir sure okay
hi Lee thank you good job Lee
West Virginia
to Patrick Morrissey Patrick thank you
Patrick
thank you thank you Patrick Ohio
attorney general Dave Yost
thank you Dave now many of you might be
worried this is the end of the speech no
Trump just started the speech by listing
people's names
a friend of mine who knows the Border
knows more about illegal immigration
than the next 10 people combined Stephen
Miller
hi Steve great good to have you here one
of my favorite generals a guy who's just
great he's got a lot of common sense and
a lot of sports yeah we're doing a lot
of Television lately and he does a
fantastic job General Keith Kellogg
thank you King pretty weird so far
a very popular man in South America very
very popular in Brazil the former
president of Brazil
bolsonaro
Trump loves those authoritarians huh
pretty vile stuff already
no you beat all these U.S politicians
that's uh that's pretty good
and his son who's a friend of mine uh
Brazilian chamber of deputies Eduardo
bolsonaro dear God truly horrible people
hi Edward great job you're doing just
got reelected and uh somebody that we
really like in this room I think I
certainly like a melody Atlanta a lot of
Courage very smart guy James Oakey
good
violence right
thank you James
good guy
As We Gather today our country and our
movement the greatest
political movement in the history of our
country is nobody gonna even question it
even the fake news media that's a lot of
fake news back there I I question and by
the way I want to thank the fire
department look at these people they're
up the rafters thank you fire department
but the greatest in our history uh most
important battle in our lives is taking
place right now as we speak ladies and
gentlemen I am here to announce I am the
most important and best person in the
history of the United States and once
you absolutely destroy it the Sinister
forces trying to kill America have done
everything they can to stop me to
silence you
and to turn this nation into a socialist
Dumping Ground for criminals junkies
marxists Thugs and dangerous dumps
refugees that no other no other country
wants them
if those opposing us succeed our once
beautiful USA will be a failed country
that no one will even recognize a
lawless open borders crime-ridden filthy
communist nightmare that's what it's
going and that's where it's going
I used to say that we will never be a
socialist country I said it oftentimes
I said it once at the State of the Union
Address and people didn't understand
what I was saying well Trump doesn't
know what socialism is and I was right
because that train has passed the
station
long ago of socialism we are now a
socialist country aim close to stopping
frankly we're now in
a Marxism State of Mind a communism
state of mind uh sir could you name one
Marxist in a position of power patient
and decline our enemies are desperate to
stop us because they know that we are
the only ones who can stop them they
know that this room
so important the people in this room
they know that we can defeat them they
know that we will defeat them but
they're not coming after me they're
coming after you and I'm just standing
in their way that's all I'm doing I'm
standing in their life hold on I'm
coming
and that's why I'm here today that's why
I'm standing before you because we are
going to finish what we started we
started something that was America
we're going to complete the
miss battle through to Ultimate victory
we're going to make America great again
again
[Music]
with you at my side we will demolish the
Deep state
we will expel the war mongers
they are people that don't get it
although in some cases they get it they
get it for their wallets but we can't do
that we can't let that happen we will
drive out the globalists we will cast
out the Communists
there are really none of any of those
let me know in the chat is he going to
bring the teach transgender line to this
speech what do you think elections no
voter ID
we will beat the Democrats we will route
the fake news media we will expose
and appropriately deal with the rhinos
we will evict jokes here we go from the
White House
a rhino named Nick Ryan and we will
liberate America from these villains and
Scoundrels once and for all
when we started this journey a journey
like there has never been before there's
never been anything like this right we
had a Republican party that was ruled by
Freaks neocons Columbus
and fools
but we are never going back to the party
of Paul Ryan Karl Rove and Jeb Bush wow
whoa
hold on a second
you might need some of those freaks sir
we're not going back to people that want
to destroy our great social security
system
even some in our own party no that might
be
that want to raise the minimum age of
Social Security to 70 75 or even 80 in
some cases he's talking about and
they're out to cut Medicare to a level
that
it will no longer be so he's talking
about DeSantis it's not a fair
characterization of what DeSantis wanted
to do but he is talking about the Santa
you have to remember that you heard it
here first
we are never going back to a party that
wants to give unlimited money to fight
Foreign Wars that are endless Wars that
are stupid Wars wow George W bush attack
but at the same time demands that we cut
veterans benefits and retirement
benefits at home our soldiers will no
longer live in the streets of our city
we have cities where
our soldiers our great soldiers are
living on
concrete they're living on asphalt we
will take care of our soldiers there has
never been a time like this
illegal immigrants come in he did
nothing for Soldiers by the way I'm in
the Waldorf Astoria and many other
of the greatest hotels anywhere in the
world
but our soldiers we do nothing for them
true they sleep out at night and they
freeze
they freeze in the cold
and they die in this is some kind of
someone talking there that was weird
illegally our in beautiful hotel suites
perhaps watching us on television right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
we were taking care of our soldiers just
a short while ago but we don't do that
anymore
but we'll start doing it again our
soldiers are very special to us
what a wonderful when I think about
empathy for the homeless and for
veterans I think of trump right away of
that town that City that Village and
prior to worrying about the rest of the
world we're taking care of the problems
of the rest of the world that they're
not taking care of themselves
they have us put up the money
you know what I'm talking about if you
look at Ukraine and we all feel so badly
about it
but why isn't NATO putting up dollar for
dollar with us
we put up 140 billion dollars
and they put up just a tiny fraction of
that and you know we all want to see
success but it's far more important to
them than it is to us because of that
location we are never going to be a
country ruled by entrenched political
dynasties in both parties rotten special
interests china-loving politicians of
which there are many
you're listening to this Mitch McConnell
are you listening oh boy
left-wing news media that's either
frightened of telling the truth or is
truly evil in bed I don't know I think I
think in many ways they're frightened
but you never really know which
we are not going back
to this from taking a sort of tear
everything down approach here which I
have to tell you I like
to live in for being here tonight and by
the way to be clear it's insanely
dangerous rhetoric I like that Trump is
self-owning to this degree
[Applause]
stay healthy Mark we can't lose you just
stay healthy
stay healthy Mark we're not going to
lose you in 2016 we took away the power
of this corrupt political class
and we did more in four years than any
Administration in the history of our
country if you look at what we're doing
we shut down the illegal foreign
invasion in our borders and achieve the
most secure Border in U.S history we
deported illegal criminal aliens by the
tens of thousands
MS-13 taking them out by the thousands
we set records every single week we were
cleaning up our country I smashed the
false Idols of the free trade Fanatics
these are fools or they're getting very
rich probably the second
and left the China Lobby reeling from
our historic tariffs and taxes that we
charge them remember uh it's the
American companies importing the Chinese
good that paid the tariffs he still
doesn't understand how tariffs work when
no other president had
gotten even 10 cents not one president
got anything from them our trade
deficits were five six seven hundred
billion dollars a year
billion think of it dollars a year not
sustainable by any country they built
their military and they have a very
powerful military with the money that we
gave them how stupid are we
I was the only president in modern
history who did not have
any new Wars no new Wars I finished some
old ones
he didn't finish any old Wars that I'm
aware of
getting sweaty already
remember when the Democrats and my
Republican opponents would often look at
me during the debates or whatever and
they'd say
no no he's going to bring us into World
War III because it's a personality type
they said I had the person no I had the
personality type that kept us out of
Wars because people knew that they
weren't going to mess around with them
they were like this guy's nuts we were
strong we were safe and I told
delinquent foreign Nations they were
delinquent they weren't paying their
bills that if they wanted our protection
they had to pay up and they had to pay
up now
and they did it paid 450 billion dollars
as soon as I said no I won't be
protecting you if you don't pay
we truly had a policy of peace through
strength this was a serious powerful
policy and we didn't have to lose our
loved ones fighting Wars in countries
that nobody's ever heard of I stood firm
against the forces of countries Trump
and many of his followers have never
heard of this two toppled statues of our
great heroes in Washington DC
they arrested them
they were knocking down the most
beautiful artwork the most beautiful
statues of great Heroes they didn't even
know who they were doing they just
wanted Anarchy and I passed and signed
an executive order anybody that does
that
gets 10 years in jail with no
negotiation it's not 10 but it turns
into three months
and it's an incredible thing that
stopped right away you know they were
heading to the Jefferson Memorial they
wanted to take out Thomas Jefferson I
don't think so
I don't think so I don't think we're
gonna let that happen
so we passed it it was a very old law
that we founded one of my very good
legal people along with you passed it or
you found it which one is it I don't
know if you want to try and bring this
back I said I do
you brought it back and as soon as we
passed it that was the end that just
stopped it's amazing it's a miracle
we ban transgender Insanity from our
military
and we will ban men and signed the
world's first ban on critical race
Theory long before anybody had even
heard of the term
Trump still is trying to figure out what
it even means
when Biden came back in
I came in and he put everything right
back in place where it was we're paying
these people hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year in salary among our
highest paid people to teach all of this
nonsense to our military yet
but it was all out it was all done
there's only one president in history
who has ever taken on the entire corrupt
establishment in Washington and when we
win in 2024 we will do it again even
stronger faster and better because
has Trump told more than a hundred lies
or fewer than a hundred lies so far let
me know in the chat
because now I am experienced and I know
the people of Washington I didn't know
them I was from New York I only came
here
17 times they said I read that in the
fake news so probably it's not true but
the best I could do and I never stayed
over
I was from New York but you never slept
I now know the good ones the bad ones
the weak ones the strong ones I know
them all I know the people that have to
do the job and can do the job a lot of
them are in this room right now
and as I did for four incredible years I
will put America First every single time
every single day
all right
from the beginning we have been attacked
by a sick and Sinister opposition the
radical left Communists the bureaucrats
the fake news media the big money
special interests the corrupt Democrat
prosecutors oh they're after me for so
many things
all those prosecutors some are racists
some hate our country they all hate me
they'll get me for anything anything
you put a comma in this paragraph why
did you do that I don't really know
the partisan it's basically
investigating Trump for grammar errors
that's all that's going on machine that
spends a lot of money on the prosecutors
by the way
the antifa thugs
who are allowed to roam the streets
while we have people
that in many cases a great Patriots
great great Patriots
saying prayers every night
playing our national anthem every day
and they're sitting
in a jail nearby rotting away and being
he's defending the Trump rioters right
now just so everybody's clear in this
country before except maybe me
and Marjorie you've been so fantastic on
that issue where's Marjorie you've been
so fantastic on that issue
and Elise and Matt
people that love our country people that
love our country have been so great on
that issue and the perverts who use the
names of Washington and Lincoln to buy
millions of dollars in ads
to say bad liveless and incorrect things
about us
there's something going on in the room
I didn't know this was a rally mat
it really is a rally when you by the way
thank you for that beautiful straw poll
that was a big win
oh man it's gonna be a long year and a
half guys
our enemies are
lunatics and Maniacs they cannot stand
that they do not own me I don't need
them I don't need anything about them I
don't need their money they cannot steer
me they cannot shake me and they will
never ever control me and they will
never ever therefore control you
at the end of the day anyone else will
be intimidated bought off blackmailed or
ripped to shreds
I alone will never Retreat and that is
why we must stand together and me with
charge we have to charge for first
glitch of the night I think a beautiful
life before I did this
I lived in luxury I had everything
people said to me are you sure you want
to do it sir I said oh this will be so
amazing sure
[Applause]
what the hell did you get me into
I didn't know the word the word Pina I
didn't know the word grand jury those
words grand jury I didn't know that
they want to Lynch you for doing nothing
wrong you know they want to let you for
doing a great job I didn't know they
want to put you away because your poll
numbers are better than anybody they've
seen in years
and then they go with the disinformation
campaign first suppose he doesn't
believe obviously we're leaving every
Republican by Massive numbers and very
importantly perhaps more importantly
we're leaving Biden by a lot and we're
leaving Kamala by Allah
and every time the polls go up higher
and higher the prosecutors get crazier
and crazier we gotta stop these guys
says we have to stop Trump now we got to
stop him now because we can't stop him
at The Ballot Box you know they tried
that in 2016 how did that work out not
too good and we actually have to say
this
I hope Fox doesn't turn off but we did
much better in 2020 than we did in 2016.
I always thoughts here but we have no
choice
if we don't do this our country will be
lost forever people are tired of rhinos
and globalists they want to see America
First can anyone in the chat name a
worse president than Donald Trump
they know it I know it you know it
everybody knows it this is it
either they win or we win and if they
win we no longer have a country and I
promise you this
if you put me back in the White House
that beautiful building but I live in
very beautiful buildings it's not that
reason
beautiful that building wasn't the
easiest building to live in
with what I was put through and you know
I get a lot of credit a lot of people
say
how do you do it sir I had a man come up
to me the other day one of the toughest
strongest people that you can imagine
big strong guy and big businessmen a lot
of a lot of success tough as hell
I said could I ask you a question
president what friend of mine used to
call me Donald now he calls me president
could I ask you a question president
what
how do you do it how do you do it every
day they send you subpoenas every day
they're after you they're looking to
take you down at the levels that
nobody's ever put up with before
seven years I've gone through this we
beat them all but it continues and he
said to me seriously how do you do it I
could never do it this is one of the
toughest guys I said maybe you could he
said nope I couldn't do it I couldn't
get out of bed in the morning but I do
it for you and that's what I'm doing
this is a real story this really
happened
thank you
honey
thank you very much and if you put me
back in the White House their reign is
over their rain will be over and they
know it and America will be a free
Nation once again we're not a free
Nation right now Free Press we don't
have free anything
in 2016 I declared I am your voice today
I add I am your Warrior I am your
Justice and for those who have been
wronged and betrayed
I am your retribution I am your
retribution not going to let this happen
a bit delusional
ism
totally obliterate the Deep State I will
fire conspiracy theories
Q Anon is loving it
this is chillingly dangerous I hope
people understand that I don't elected
bureaucrats and Shadow forces who have
weaponized our justice system like it
has never been weaponized before sick
these are sick people
and I will put the people back in charge
of this country again the people will be
back in charge of our country
the Biden Administration is the most
corrupt Administration in American
history why Hunter Biden is a criminal
and nothing happened to him nothing
happened he has nothing to do with the
administration criminal and nothing ever
seems to happen to him
because you know
say what you want but the Democrats
stick together
they don't have Mitt Romney they don't
have guys like that they they stick
together how's Mitt Romney doing not too
good
I could name plenty of others too a
rhino name but they do stick together
whether you like them or not and many of
us don't but maybe someday we get
together you know a question was asked
of me
just before covet came in
they said the country is coming together
do you think this is real
sure and I said to myself it is real
it's amazing I was getting calls from
radical left people the nicest calls
it's amazing because we had the best
employment numbers in history we had the
best economy in history we were lapping
China China was supposed to have taken
over as the world's largest economy and
we were actually increasing at a level
that nobody thought for us but we were
doing great and then you had covet come
in and a lot of things had to happen and
we did this is exhausting I'm with you
guys yeah did a great job with covet and
then gave back something very strong but
we were really bringing this country
together had coveted not come in I think
you would have had a much different
because a lot of people want to know can
we all get along together and I if I
didn't have that experience I would say
no because the you know the thought
process is so different but we were
starting to really get along and then we
had the disasters now you might not
remember that because it didn't happen I
want to be open and I want to be
I want to be accurate
but Biden openly held back a billion
dollar taxpayer
old taxpayer money
for the government of Ukraine remember
he said until they fired a prosecutor
when they fired that prosecutor
and this prosecutor was after Hunter and
the company that was paying him a
Fortune of money remember Joe Biden
stood up and said and I looked at them
and I said you're not getting that
billion dollars you're not yet until you
get rid of that I can't believe he did
that can you imagine if I did that
I wouldn't be here right now I suspect
and nobody picks it up nobody wants to
pick it up it doesn't get any worse does
it get any worse than that although
maybe it does it's called the laptop for
Mel
and yet they go
[Music]
which was a plan made up by crooked
Hillary Clinton Adam Shifty shift and
I've been here
I'll be back in five they then made up
a fake phone call they took a phone call
that was perfect and they pretended that
I said things that weren't even and they
actually imitated remember Schiff he
stood up in Congress and he repeated the
call
like I was a gangster
over and over again quid pro quo
remember the term quit broken but it
wasn't I called downstairs at the White
House I said listen do we have that call
taped because there's no way I said
those things
and they called back and tell me yes sir
we do essentially with transcripts of
the call thank goodness we had
transcripts because these guys were
they're sick they're sick people and
they were looking to do
a number I'll tell you how bad they are
so and I tell this story seldom but it's
a strong story Monica
thank you very much for the great job
you do by the way what a Defender she is
but
they're so bad so they come up with this
Russia Russia Russia hoax and they know
it's a hoax they know it's Elks I know
it's a hoax too
but they know it's a hoax and Adam
Shifty shift comes out from a very
secretive room intelligence committee or
whatever
and he meets the Press right in front
the Press is going crazy they're going
crazy because they'll do anything to
hurt Trump anything they're evil people
in many cases some cases they're great
people but a lot of evil people
and he stands up before a microphone now
this is a man who knows it's a fake
story Russia Russia Russia I had not
they checked six years of phone calls
millions of calls were made from my
office that one call to Russia
not one girl that was surprised they
weren't surprised but some people were
surprised but he stood up before the
microphones
and he said Donald Trump Jr will go to
prison
for what he has done
with Russia my son my son is going to go
to prison he said my son's going to go
to prison for what he's done with Russia
and my son didn't
have anything to do with it and he knew
it was a fake story and when it was
finally revealed now the times the
worship will say well admit it was a
fake story we're trying to get the
Pulitzer Prize taken away they got
Pulitzer prizes we're suing
you know what the prize says for its
concise and accurate reporting on the
russia-russia Russia event
and they haven't actually totally wrong
actually Mark Levin should get a prize
and Greg Jarrett Greg Jarrett should get
her prize
and even it's not his deal
Sean Hannity
should get a prize and frankly Jesse
should get a surprise
Jessica
and a lot of people and I tell you you
know we should get a prize Tucker should
get a price Tucker
a very strong
and we have numerous writers that you
get it but the ones that got it
were the New York Times certain
reporters from The New York Times and
certain reports from the Washington Post
they got the Pulitzer Prize and they
were exactly wrong and now they've even
admitted
that it was a hoax it was a total hoax
and they got the price but how bad is a
person that stands before a big gaggle
of press and they just can't get enough
and says that my son is going to prison
for something that he knows was a hoax
only a really bad person would do that
but they then came in with Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine by the way programming
note Adam Schiff will be on the show
Tuesday present himself
at the hearings it wasn't too pretty but
you know what I'll say this at least
they came to the right conclusion
because I was concerned they'd come to
the conclusion I think we have
prosecutors now they don't give a damn
if you're guilty they're looking at me
in Atlanta on a perfect phone call I
said even more perfect than my perfect
call
to Ukraine that was a perfect call this
is even more perfect
[Applause]
give me a break but where's Hunter
will there ever be a time when Joe Biden
says
this thing with Hunter just isn't
working out well
I'm starting to get a little angry at
Hunter
or when Hunter comes to him and says Dad
we have a problem what what is a son
another one oh son your disaster side
son you're a disaster what's funny is
Joe Biden actually seems to love his
kids
[Music]
and Joe looks at him and says
what's on it son what's on it
and Hunter looks back and he says every
single crime that you've ever committed
there
and
hence is called
the laptop from hell and Miranda Devine
did a great book on that and she
actually thanked me she said I got
Trump trump
you said I want to thank you for the
name I said no charge
she did she did a great job great book
the laptop from hell why won't you
everybody in the chat is like tell us
the crimes why won't you guys just
accept it and also Obama gate which was
the biggest political crime of the 21st
and 20th centuries just accept it that's
it dangerous and violent cities in the
United States great to see this United
States where killings are taking place
at a number like nobody's ever seen
right in Manhattan and he's doing
nothing about it nothing whatsoever
no cash bail
for people that just kill people
knife them in the back hit him over the
head with a baseball bat push them into
Subways when this train is right there
but this racist
D.A is being pushed by
radical left Democrats the fake news
media and the department of Injustice
charges against me for
now ancient know Affair story of Stormy
horse face Daniels no attraction
no Affair like oh no affair
where there is no crime anyway
and charges have never been brought in
such a case before and this case has
been looked by every prosecutor they're
all looking they looked at it for years
now she was represented by Michael
avenatti how's he doing
he's now in jail
and the whole thing is a complete con
job
and she was ordered to pay me a federal
court order this Trump paid her off of
dollars
but they're still looking at it
they're still looking
and all they do is they cause anger and
problems for our country because our
people aren't going to take this stuff
it never ends in the meantime Hunter and
Joe Biden skate you know they skate they
go
they go away free what's going on with
that I mean that laptop is a disaster
how can it be possible they're looking
in Delaware how's he doing
he's not the same guy that I have for
the document Oaks I have a man who's a
total animal
known to be and he's looking looking in
the meantime Biden's guy that's looking
looking don't forget
I had a very strong privilege as
president
I was able to do things that he wasn't
able to do as vice president and wasn't
able to do as a senator the Senate
imagine clapping for like executive
privilege is weird I cannot believe it
but when you look at what happened
they're not even looking at him they
haven't even started Congress and
various radical left Democrat
prosecutors in an effort to stop me go
to the Supreme Court twice they went
twice in the Supreme Court can someone
honestly explain to me why Trump's right
eye is almost completely swollen shut I
I never have gotten a satisfactory
answer about that
but they found nothing they looked at 11
million pages of documents it's a big
company it's a great company
remember my taxes where if there is
taxes five years I heard about my taxes
they came out about two months ago
everyone said wow it's a great company
he built that's great
that's the end of it
no right
and you know I had
the biggest and most prestigious one of
them at least law firms accounting firms
doing all this stuff I don't do it they
do it you rely on these people they do
it but I didn't hear one word
and how stupid am I telling you this
story right now because now then we
gotta find something in there he made a
typographical era
there's a Revolution going on within the
FBI because they don't want to be doing
what they're being told to do because
they know
right from wrong I'm talking about the
people that work in the FBI and they
like me and they like you a lot so many
of them a recent article in the
Washington Post of all papers stated
very succinctly that many did not want
to raid Mar-A-Lago they didn't want the
agents they said that's terrible
but they were forced to do so by their
Marxist radical left leadership yes
including the director of the FBI who
Trump had selected Trump selected a
Marxist to lead the FBI isn't that the
best it's not supposed to work though
Mark when Nixon got impeached it went
down right it was a spiraled down he
couldn't stop it I got a peach we went
up
but the FBI people they didn't want to
do this
to those in the FBI that are with us I
want to thank you very much I really do
I want to thank you
stay strong
stay strong help is coming
then there's the racist D.A from Atlanta
whose city is among the most violent and
dangerous places per capita in the
country
more murders than even Chicago per
capita
it's totally out of control in that she
has her Kangaroo Court focused on a
perfect phone call that I made well you
know what city is pretty damn dangerous
per capita Oklahoma City Trump never
mentions it I wonder why interviews and
saying exactly what's going on in this
one of many grand juries
our opponents do anything they can to
hurt me politically because they're
afraid of me and they're afraid of you
that's what it is
but it's not supposed to work that way
the disinformation people say they are
great at this information
the one we want to run against is Trump
do you ever hear that oh we want to run
a trump even though I'm leading every
one of these guys and even though I won
the second election okay I want to buy a
lot you know when they say when they say
Biden won
the smart people know that didn't you
but right now we're way up but they say
oh we want to run against Trump they
always say that they say that about
everybody when they have somebody that
they don't want to run against
so is it unique to Trump that they're
saying that or do they say they want to
run against everybody which is the two
is it
I mean I got 75 million votes I got more
votes than any City president in history
the second time and we really did we did
a much better job than we did in 2016.
2020 we did better than
2016. but they say we want to run
against Trump in the meantime they're
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
trying to find just a single word a
sentence anything
to prosecute Trump because they don't
want to run against me that's what they
say we want to run against Trump we'll
do anything to run against Trump
uh they have the greatest line of
of any group of people
[Applause]
[Music]
want to run against lost my eight
million vote
but at the same time they send people
from the justice department to the local
DA's Office of Manhattan do you know the
justice department sent their top people
to the Manhattan DA's office to help in
the prosecution of trump this way we
have it a little bit away from
Washington
local oh we had nothing to do but the
top guy was put in that office to help
prosecute Trump how would you like to
have my life would anybody like my life
but I still like it
[Applause]
when they've already been
exonerated I've been exonerated many
times you take a look at what this I
mean time after time but all of this is
happening for one single reason they
know that when we return to power we
will bring their lies and their
corruption and their disinformation
tumbling down
tumbling
we're getting back in the White House
is their worst nightmare
but it is our country's only hope it's
our only hope if we don't get back
now this country can't take it even the
two years and now fortunately it's less
than that's hard to believe it's less
used to say four years a lot of people
said well sir
the election was so bad you'll be in sir
a lot of people in this room you'll be
back in six weeks sir
but it's uh it turns out there was no
law that allowed for that system
but nobody else can do it but us in
recent weeks I've been
laying out a bowl detailed agenda for
how we're going to complete this mission
in our next term I do weekly statements
and people are liking them today I want
to go through some of our big plans that
I will do as the 47th president of the
United States
okay
thank you
at the top of my list we'll be stopping
the slide into costly and never-ending
Wars we've got to stop it can't keep
spending hundreds of billions of dollars
protecting people
that don't even like us now you know in
business if you did that what you do is
you put up the money and then you say
but listen we own half your country in
case you win
you know you take a piece of The Upside
right we get nothing in fact the
opposite we put our money and then after
it's finished assuming it's successful
let's say it's successful they don't
want to even talk to us no you have
nothing to do with us get out of here
you have nothing no no in business you
put up money seed money call it whatever
you want you end up owning the country
by the time it's over
and the only reason they're doing well
is we're giving them the greatest
equipment that I bought the greatest
equipment
ever made
and the only reason they're doing well
with NATO is I raised 440 billion
dollars from countries that weren't
paying anything
and the Secretary General
Sultan or a good man he said it's one of
the greatest jobs I've ever seen I hope
he still says that but one of the
greatest jobs he said Obama would come
and make a speech Bush would come out
make a speech and then they'd leave
I came I looked I said man these people
aren't paying we're paying for the whole
thing practically
of the 28 countries at the time only
eight were paid up 20 weren't including
Germany they paid a fraction of what
they were supposed to be paying
and I said to him
either you pay
we're not going to protect you and a man
stood up
a president of a country stood up and he
said sir can I ask you a question this
was around table with nobody in the room
but the presidents
prime minister and dictators okay some
of them are all the same
but they stood up
and he stood up and said sir could I ask
you a question sir if we don't pay up
and if we get attacked by Russia
will you protect us sir
I said no you're not paid up right
that's right you're delinquent right yes
I will not protect you from Russia sir
we'll send you
send you sir
does anyone in my audience believe that
conversation happened said
[Applause]
they absolutely will be you know
article five six seven eight nine well
you're supposed to do it but those
articles all suppose that you're
supposed to be paid up but let's say I
said the opposite let's yes we will
always protect you I took a lot of heat
because they said I'm not a good member
to actually NATO wouldn't even exist if
I didn't get them to pay up but they
paid up 449 billion dollars or something
and that's the money they use they're
rich as hell right now they spent an
office building
that cost three billion dollars it's
like a skyscraper in Manhattan
later on its side it's one of the
longest buildings I've ever seen
and I said you should have instead of
spending
three billion dollars you should have
spent
500 million dollars building the
greatest bunker you've ever seen because
Russia didn't wouldn't even need an
airplane attack one tank one shot
through that beautiful glass building
and it's gone same architect I used in
Chicago great Architects but they didn't
have war in mind
but when things happen that building
would be gone at about 15 minutes they
should have spent the 500 million dollar
bunker nice thick ceiling six inches six
feet of concrete and by the way we have
a great gentleman speaking of chatter
will you please stand up Gordon stand up
please
Gordon chair
Trump highlighting a neocon now um we
will open phone lines when this is done
if people want uh if we get to 100
website members and twitch subscribers
and I'm just
[Applause]
but it's for exciting and I'm looking at
Gordon and I'm saying you know I hope he
agrees with what I'm saying but
basically I'm saying exactly what you
say they're not out for our good are
they they're not out for our good and
nobody ever texts them like I did and
nobody ever took any money in like I did
440 billion we took in we took in so
much money from China it's so incredible
so I just it's an honor to have you here
really it is I agree with hope
everything you say
almost everything great thank you very
much
thank you madam thank you very much
great job both of you
I was the only president in decades that
didn't have
a war but I completed Wars that were
already started including defeating 100
of the Isis caliphate with the Colorado
War
I was also the only President where
Russia didn't take over a country during
my term
Russia pretty deceptive right I mean did
nothing about Crimea from previously and
then also allowed Russia to establish
and solidify its presence in the Donetsk
and the luhansk so a little weird
framing here 10 and president XI
believed it when I talked about Beijing
he probably said I don't believe him but
there's a 10 chance we're not going to
do anything it's true it's true you have
no idea these conversations I wish they
could have been recorded actually people
would think a lot of me
but with bush
they invaded Georgia right
with Obama they took Crimea Obama with
Biden they're trying to take everything
and he won't even know they took it
come on
oh boy
what are they yelling and with me they
took nothing nothing
and I didn't really even have to
threaten them very much they understood
me very well I wanted them very well
they knew that they couldn't do it
Putin knew that President she knew it
too likewise China now has its eyes
strongly focused on Taiwan
and we could soon have a
nuclear armed Iran that's the saddest
thing of all though when we talk about
Iran Trump got out of the Iran nuclear
deal that Iran had abided by up until
that point Trump is the one to blame for
this Iran
they said no no we have to buy we buy
we'd buy millions of barrels here and I
said you can't buy you have to buy from
somebody else no no we'll buy I said
good we're not going to do any more
trading with China we're going cold
turkey we will promise you not to buy
from Iran okay that was the end of that
you know that was a conversation I had I
said if you buy from a rent
any oil we're not going to do any
business or if for some reason we do
we're going to put a hundred percent
tariff on every single thing that you
sell into the United States and they
didn't buy any oil and nobody was buying
oil and they were in a position
had the election
that turned out the way it did they were
in a position where they were going to
give us everything we were going to make
a great deal but now they're rich again
China is buying unlimited amounts of oil
from Iran unlimited amounts and other
places and we've done something else
that's terrible from the time I'm a
young man I learned never allow Russia
and China
to get together to Wed never ever allow
it and we've not only allowed it we've
made them Bosom Buddies we've made them
we forced them together and you can add
another group in there a nuclear-armed
Iran so the three of them are now
together that should have never been
allowed to happen would have never
happened with me and it was all over oil
our stupid oil policy
we're not going to do it we have more
oil in the United States
than any country in the world including
Saudi Arabia people don't realize it
in Alaska
I approved a site we all know what the
site is
probably the biggest in the world
and the Democrats said no it's over they
turned it down Ronald Reagan tried to do
it every president Republican and some
Democrats tried to do it they couldn't
get it done I got it done
and the first day in office the
secretary
of the interior for Biden
signed off on it where they're gonna not
Lo allow it to happen bigger probably
than Saudi Arabia
and if we had that without even my
talking to Putin oil would have been
at forty dollars thirty five dollars
maybe thirty dollars a barrel so he
wouldn't have even had the money to
prosecute a war
against Ukraine he wouldn't have done it
anyway but and that's not even what I'm
saying from previous Trump trump
increasingly struggling syntactically
and grammatically which is a sign maybe
that uh he's having having a problem
here
and there would have been no obliterated
cities that can never be rebuilt can
never rebuild those cities
Russia never would have pulled the
trigger this is the most dangerous time
in the history of our country and Joe
Biden
is leading us into Oblivion Oblivion
he's leading us into Oblivion you know
we all smile when he falls down stairs
and things it's cute when he falls off
his bicycle
you know what amazed me that the
reporters didn't catch him when the bike
was going down they're standing right
next to him they let him fall
[Applause]
it's amazing
I'm surprised
[Applause]
but when he makes statements that are so
bad when he gets out of Afghanistan and
takes the soldiers takes think of it
takes the soldiers out first
and you know in Afghanistan
for 18 months I had a talk with Abdul he
was the leader of Afghanistan I said
Abdul oh I got a lot of criticism
remember when I was talking to him
everyone said oh he's talking to
the leader of the Taliban that's right
because our show our soldiers were being
killed a lot of them by snipers and I
didn't want that I don't want to deal
with
the problems and I don't want to talk to
the mothers and fathers who I would
speak to a lot
I don't want to talk to them and tell
them their son was shot through the head
from 2 000 yards away by a sharpshooter
they have very good Sharpshooters so I
spoke to this man his name was Abdul and
I said Abdul
don't kill any more I showed him a
picture of it now kill our soldiers
we're going to hit you harder than any
country has ever been hit in the history
of the world
and he called me your Excellency he was
you know I got along he's still there
he's still the he's still the leader of
the Taliban but now he's got 85 billion
dollars worth of our equipment that I
bought
85 billion I said to General milley I
want every piece of equipment sure I
think it would be cheaper to leave it
behind sir that's what I lost faith that
and when he didn't like me holding up a
Bible in front of a church I said this
guy's not with us this is not a this is
not a smart guy
but he didn't like it I said
I want everything because I was getting
out of but I would have kept Bagram
because bagram's one hour away from
where China forget about Afghanistan
where China makes its nuclear weapons
one hour away the biggest most powerful
runways in the world we built it many
years ago for tens of billions of
dollars
and we gave it away one night we just
left left the lights on we did leave the
dogs behind everyone says oh did they
take the dogs because they're dog lovers
right no we left the dogs
doesn't like dogs by the way not at all
but we we left
in disgrace it was the most embarrassing
moment in the history of our country in
my opinion and it probably is what
caused Putin to say well Trump is gone
this is a great time to take over
Ukraine right it's probably think of how
delusional that is
uh Biden getting out of Afghanistan was
the most embarrassing moment in the
history of the country and it made Putin
think hey I should invade Ukraine World
War III very easily
and you're going to have world war three
by the way you're going to have world
war three if something doesn't happen
fast you're going to have world work
this is real and by the way
just to conclude that little story
when Abdul
heard me say that
he said your Excellency thank you so
much for telling me that
he said but why but why I thought it was
a very interesting plan which I've never
heard it I use it now sometimes for
myself I liked it
he said but why but why Mr President
do you send me pictures of my home
[Applause]
I said you'll have to ask your wives
that question
[Applause]
Soldier killed oh my God 18 months not
one soldier was killed
not one soldier right
in fact it was so good this is so bad it
make it just makes you cringe why do you
call him
I said well you know they asked Jesse
James the great bank robber from many
years ago
why is it that you rubbed Banks what
I've had more investigations than Jesse
James Billy the could well I spoke to
Abdul because that's where the problem
was
but we won 18 months until that horrible
day
when we lost 13 soldiers and you know
the thing that nobody ever talks about
we lost 13 we lost 85 billion dollars
worth of the greatest military equipment
in the world goggles night goggles that
are so good so sophisticated better than
anything we have brand new never even
taken out of the box
and you know the Afghans and and they're
actually very good the Taliban and good
Fighters Afghan because it's really very
much the same thing frankly they didn't
fight good for us but they fought they
fought good for themselves and they took
a lot of money from us I asked quite a
historical analysis we got to get out of
there they've been there for 20 years we
got to get out of there sure
sir
that's right I guess they are then about
two days later I was thinking about it I
said I don't know why because you know
we had more
uh blue on green green on Blue where
they get their gun and then they'd shoot
or Master sergeants and our sergeants
that are training them I said why are
they fighting for us if we've never had
this problem to the extent that we had
it
but he said that he said they're farting
and I said
are we paying them a lot of money to
fight
and I had it checked
yeah we were paying billions and
billions and billions of dollars to
these
Afghan soldiers
tens almost completely lost this train
of thought there I said they're not
fighting General I called them back in
they're not fighting because they love
us so they love their country they're
fighting because they're the highest
paid soldiers in the world
we're basically bribing them to fight
and they didn't fight but the Taliban
did fight same people but the Taliban
they didn't fight but the Taliban did he
really has a way with words really
weaves a story where you feel like
you're in it and he actually said that
they didn't kill anybody I will say that
they didn't kill anybody for 18 months
and you know what happened his people
start screaming don't say that
because that's a good thing for us
but then when we left we lost
we lost soldiers 13. imagine sitting
there in the seventh row and listening
to this stuff now going on an hour and
going man this is this is really great
stuff they're the we've lost contact
with it's a rough place
but they don't talk about the fact that
many of these soldiers were absolutely
destroyed
destroyed they lost their arms
they lost their legs they had their face
blown off
and they were absolutely
destroyed and they don't talk about that
they don't talk about it and it's uh
it's very sad because these people many
of them we lost their team they died but
nobody ever talks about the gravity of
the injuries to these soldiers and it's
a very sad thing I got it down to 2 500
people
I was the one that got it down but we
were going to get out with dignity with
strength we're going to be respected and
admired
and I could just see Abdul
they took out the soldiers first you
don't take the soldiers first you take
the soldiers out last you get the
Americans out first because they feared
our soldiers really inspiring speech
here teens and now they own them
think of it you get the soldiers and
they go out last you take our American
citizens out you then take our equipment
out
and Millie said to me search cheaper to
leave the equipment than it is to take
it out I said let me ask you General so
we have a plan that cost a hundred
million dollars brand new you want to
live yes sir super sir
I thought he was you know another April
Fool's deal right I thought
I said no General you fill it up with a
tank of jet fuel
you fly it back home or at a minimum you
fly it into Pakistan or some
semi-friendly country and you take it
from there right no sir I actually told
them I want the tents you know the tents
have big canvas incredible tents with
this I want every piece of Steel I want
every screw or whatever Trump loves
canvas I want every tractor
I want every Jeep
you know what they did they left 700
000 rifles and guns seven hundred
thousand they left 70 000 Vehicles
seventy thousand many of them brand new
many of them armor plated where they
have six inches of Steel in the bottom
cost you millions of dollars to build
and they left that all behind there's
not a
car company used car lot new car lot
anywhere in the world
that would have 70 000 vehicles
I said to a friend of mine who's one of
the Arrigo in Florida great guy
I said how many cars he's I think he's
like the biggest in Florida
they sold they did very well thank you
but the biggest I said how many cars
would you have under a couple hundred
extra a couple of hundred and he's like
a big one real big one runs a great
operation
70 000 vehicles
so now I read the other day that the
Taliban that Afghanistan
is the second largest seller of arms
anywhere in the world because they're
selling everything that we gave them
and by the way as I'm speaking do I see
cash is that cash oh my eyes are better
than I thought okay
presumably referring to cash pot and
other conspiracy theorists wow
I better check with Gordon and I better
check this audience a little more
closely I'm going to miss a lot of
people in here a great two real Patriots
there really are two great people thank
you very much
but they're the second largest to us
there's the second largest arms dealer
in the world they're selling off all the
beautiful brand new equipment we gave
them the Apache helicopter which is the
best in the world
they gave one to Russia gave it they
gave one to China and they're very good
they take it apart and they reduplicate
it they take it apart
they reduplicate it because they've
never been able to build one like we
have now they're able to do it because
they're very smart actually
before I even arrive at the Oval Office
I will have the disastrous war between
Russia and Ukraine settled it will be
settled quickly
I will get the problem solved and I will
get it solved in Rapid order
and it will take me no longer than one
day I know exactly what to say to each
of them I got along with very well I
know you all know about all of Trump's
absurd failed predictions from 2016. he
seems to be making even more absurd
predictions for 2024. remember it was
wall with Mexico that they will pay for
Jared will solve israeli-palestinian
conflict in one year replacement for
ObamaCare none of it happened right
nobody ever heard of Nordstrom 2 until I
came along I started talking about
Nordstrom too I had to go go with the
pipeline because nobody knew what I was
talking about
but I ended it it was dead I told every
company that had sucked into it that
you're not doing business with the
United States of America if you go
forward and allow this to be built it
was done on day one
Biden came in
and this is the biggest economic
development project this is the most
important project that Russia has on day
one this is the biggest money they could
ever make there's nothing they could
ever do to compete with us it's the
biggest pipeline in the world
going to supply Europe Germany in
particular on day one Biden came in and
what did he do he approved The North
Ship hotline and then they'd say Trump
was soft on Russia I was the one that
gave a thousand javelins that's the
anti-take Busters and they are vicious
because I looked at those tanks and they
ended up they got hit one shot and that
was the end of that that you wouldn't
want to be in those tanks right but I
was the one that supplied the javelins
they supplied the bed sheets do you
remember
they supplied the bed sheets and maybe
even some pillows from Mike who's
sitting right over here where the hell
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines Maybe
but they supplied the bed sheets they
call it we supplied the sheets they
didn't want to get involved I gave the
javelins and then they say Trump was
weak on Russia
disinformation again it's disinformation
right that's all they're good at
cheating on elections and disinformation
instead of spending hundreds of billions
of dollars to defend the borders of
distant foreign countries under my
leadership we will defend our borders
first
three years ago we had the safest Border
in the history of our country and I will
quickly do that again
as you know I built hundreds of miles of
wall and completed that task as promised
and then I began to add even more in
areas that remember the task he promised
was
border wall
entire U.S Mexico border
paid for by Mexico
by the end of his first term
none of that happened Paul was sitting
there waiting to be installed the
easiest part
and Biden they took it away so that
Texas and Arizona couldn't use it Texas
and Arizona said could we
use that wall we'll finish it right up
and they said no and they actually took
it away and they hid it they put it in a
hiding area which of course was revealed
pretty quickly all you have to do is
send a couple of helicopters up
but they wouldn't let him use it under
my leadership we will seal it up and
expand that wall till we have total
control
a reasonable question would be sir the
promise you made in the first term about
the wall failed miserably why should we
believe that you would do it now well
sir if you approved this budget we'll
give it to you next year I'll say all
right that's okay so I waited then they
didn't give it you know and yet Mitch
McConnell approves five and a half
trillion dollars for the green New Deal
garbage
it's a disgrace but I took it from the
military because I considered it an
invasion so Marjorie I said you know
what I'm going to do I'm going to take
it right out of the military because
they're invading our country and I got
it built and we did a great job we did
it quickly and we used the Army Corps of
Engineers that were fantastic before
Biden came into office we had illegal
immigration at a record low refugees
were at the lowest level in history
you've been trafficking women and
children was at the lowest in 30 years
and drug dealers were finding the U.S
border a very
inhospitable place to be he was very
inhospitable
in my last year less drugs came through
the southern border that had been seen
in many many decades we weren't playing
games now we have complete chaos
fentanyl is pouring in families are
being wiped out destroyed and there's
death everywhere all caused by
incompetence
millions of illegal aliens are
stampeding across our border this has
been a long speech it's been shut down
everyone is overstaying their visas
nobody even thinks about reporting it
anymore we're already up to 73 minutes
and he doesn't seem to be slowing down
Refugee numbers are through the roof
and spies and terrorists are
infiltrating our country totally
unchecked like never before when I'm
back in the White House the very first
reconciliation bill I will sign will be
for a massive increase in Border Patrol
and a colossal increase in the number of
ice deportation officers
and I want to thank the border patrol
these are incredible people
and I want to thank ice and in
particular I want to thank Brandon Judd
border patrol and Tom Holman Central
casket he's Central cast
under my leadership we will use all
necessary State local Federal and
Military resources to carry out the
largest domestic deportation operation
in American history
out there prisons
[Applause]
asylums and mental institutions and
sending all of their problems
right into their Dumping Ground that is
not happening period there is no
evidence of that so emptying out their
mental institutions and uh to use a
strong couple of words insane asylum
insane asylum that's where anybody see
Silence of the Lamb that's where they
come from and save yourself that's a
stronger word than a mental institution
right and they're putting them into our
country thank you very much I will ask
every state and federal agency to
identify every known or suspected gang
member in America and every one of them
that is here illegally and the towns
know who they are the towns and cities
or the police we love our police the
police know who they are
it's not just scary that Trump says this
stuff
it's really scary that there's anyone in
this country so ignorant or gullible
that they would believe it and as I've
said before
you have people that rant right I mean
Trump guy in the subway whatever
uh but the fact that there are millions
of people that believe this stuff
where's people these are absolute brutal
girl as they used to knife 16 year old
girls because it was more painful it
would take longer to kill her
these are real animals and Nancy pelosis
how dare you call them animals these are
human beings I said they're not but
these are real animals and we couldn't
get them back into their countries
because the country was like especially
three
you take a look at Guatemala El Salvador
special Honduras in particular and
Mexico to an extent you couldn't get
them back in because they didn't want
them they sent them out in the first
place you know they forced them into our
country just so you know these are very
smart people to run these places they're
very Street Boys
so I said what's the problem sir we have
thousands of people but they won't allow
us to land the planes that won't allow
the buses to cross the border they won't
allow them back in their country I say
how much money do we pay to these
various countries sir we pay 750 million
dollars a year
I say all right inform the country that
we're no longer paying any money
and if they ask why you can tell them
and yes sir we'll do that so the
following morning almost simultaneously
early about eight o'clock
I got calls from all three at one time
in fact I had to tell two of them I'll
call you back
because they all came in right on time
Matt
right on time like you call on time and
what happens is
they came in and they called they said
sir
there must be a misunderstanding
we would love to have MS-13 back in our
country
and we started dropping them off by the
tens of thousands and I still hadn't
paid them back that money I kept it
figured let's hold it as long as
possible because they've been ripping us
off long enough
to stop the flow of deadly drugs it will
be my policy to take down the cartels
just as I took down
the Isis caliphate that everybody said
was impossible to do
a lot of parents in this audience
that lost the child and lost a loved one
to Fentanyl and all of the drugs that
are pouring and so many different kinds
fentanyl is a big problem
in fact with the Isis caliphate a
certain General said
It could only be done in three years and
probably it can't be done at all sir
and I did it in three weeks I went over
to Iraq met a great General
sir I can do it in three weeks you've
heard that story
I could do it in three weeks sir how are
you going to do that they explained it I
did it in three weeks I was told it
couldn't be done at all but it would
take at least three years did it in
three weeks knocked out 100 of the Isis
gallery
we have a great military the reason I
say that we have a great military and I
will Direct
the Department of Justice to go after
Marxist Prosecutor's offices to make
them pay for their illegal that should
be a quick uh process since I can't
think of any Marxist prosecutors
by the way we have one of those great
generals with us General Kellogg where's
General Kellogg is he around here where
is General kelloggy's the greatest he's
here thank you General thank you thank
you General
and in cities where there's been a
complete breakdown of Public Safety
I will send in federal assets including
the National Guard until Law and Order
is restored you know we're not supposed
to do that
some difficulty in certain cities like
Minneapolis and uh if you take a look at
Portland how's Portland doing they don't
even have cell fronts anymore
everything's two by fours because they
get burned down every week they don't
put new stories
chaos but when we had in Seattle
remember they took over a large portion
I was ready to send in the National
Guard they heard that more than the
National Guard I was ready to go to town
and they heard that and you know what
they did they said uh we're gonna break
it up now they left but we saved
Minneapolis the thing is we're not
supposed to do that because it's up to
the governor the Democrat Governor they
never want any help they don't mind it's
almost like they don't mind to have
their cities and states destroyed
there's something wrong with these
people all of us have seen too many
videos of 13 year old carjackers and 14
year old hoodlums viciously beating
their victims
saw it just yesterday in horrible
situation they killed people without
retribution because they may be days
short of the age required to
put them away put them in jail and throw
away the keys for a long time my
Administration will crack down on these
out of control monsters young though
they may be an imposed tough
consequences on juvenile criminals you
know criminals use young people they
actually they have to run on death
penalty for juveniles some money not a
lot because if they get caught nothing's
gonna happen to them that will end I
will end the scourge of homelessness
taken over our cities
I just drove through Washington D.C
coming here for the first time in quite
a while and the roads and highways were
littered with trash like I've never seen
before it looked like somebody just took
their garbage and just
threw it all over the highways the
Beltway it's so disgraceful so
disgusting I always made it a point as
president when I saw the highways were
dirty or that the homeless encampments
were starting to form to take care of
the problem immediately I used to have
people out here all the time
sweeping highways cleaning highways
hosing them down it it bothered me so
much I'm in the Beast I'm being driven
back to the White House from some site
and I see this filthy dirty Highway with
with paper that hasn't been you could
see it's been laying there for months
paper and I'd have them cleaned up I
wouldn't even call them there because it
was never going to get done with the
mayor frankly the federal government
should take over control and management
of Washington D.C
good project
all right folks we're hopefully getting
down to the end we'll open phone lines
once again if you're watching on Twitch
great time to re-up your Twitch Prime
subscription we will open phone lines if
we get to 100 I expect this will go
somewhere between five and five hundred
more minutes the streets are much better
much better maintained much nicer
and uh they see camps and homeless all
over our beautiful once beautiful Parks
all over hundreds and hundreds of tents
I used to have them taken down on media
I'd see one or two or three I said do it
fast immediately then I check and it was
done
they'd never have time to do once they
have 500 600 700 of these things up it's
a much more difficult thing but you can
do that too
under our leadership we will take the
homeless drug addicted and severely
deranged get them off our streets and
create tent cities where I guess they're
taking Trump if you're including
severely deranged
on day one I will revoke Joe Biden's
crazy executive order installing Marx's
diversity equity and inclusions ours in
every Federal agency and I will
immediately terminate all staffers hired
to implement this
horrible agenda didn't happen literally
did not happen
I will urge Congress to create a
restitution fund for Americans who have
been unjustly discriminated against by
these Biden policies they're so unfair
they're so Un-American they're so
un-American and we will ban all racial
discrimination by the government
I will fight for parents rights can you
believe that here we are and I'm saying
I'm going to fight for parents rights
who would think that you have to ever
say parents rights don't you think
parents have pretty good rights right
who would think that you have to
actually say all right is he going to do
teach transgender is he going to do it
reversal school choice and the direct
election of school principals by the
parents we want the school principal
to be appointed and elected by parents
and you'll get some good principles then
who loves the children more than the
parents
if any principle is not getting the job
done the parents should be able to fire
that principal immediately and select
someone there
continuing the work of our 1776
commission we will teach our values and
promote our history and our Traditions
to our children we will in other words
be proud of our country again
[Music]
I will revoke every Biden policy
promoting the chemical castration and
sexual mutilization utilization
and ask Congress to send me a bill
prohibiting child sexual mutilation in
all 50 states
that should be easy
and we will keep men out of women's
sports
and we will ban men
how ridiculous
that will take place on day one I will
destroy the illegal censorship regime
and bring back free speech in America
because we do not have physical and I
will stop Joe Biden's demolition of her
economy with his crushing inflation and
mass layoffs we will take care of
inflation very very quickly
4.9 million people have dropped out of
the labor force
since I was President most of them
because they retired administrations
great Larry Kudlow does everybody know
Larry
as Larry Kudlow said Biden is setting a
record on economic regulations
that are absolutely Killing American
companies his spending and his borrowing
are at record levels it's causing
historic inflation sir which is only
going to get worse and worse he's sir
he's just told me before I got I said I
want to say this Larry
it's only going to get worse and worse
it's driving up interest rates and new
cars and homes are going to be
impossible to buy amidst this economic
disaster Biden talks about saving you a
few dollars on some junk fees don't mean
anything by defeating Joe Biden I will
save your economy I will save your
retirement accounts and I will save your
jobs we had the greatest job history of
any president ever I will create a true
National trade policy like the kind that
made America the world's economic
Powerhouse what we were doing prior to
the
dust coming in from China was nobody's
ever seen it there's never been anything
like it that period of I see a lot of
people asking it has been 85 minutes 85
minutes of trump speaking we are getting
very close to an hour and a half dollars
on Military protection that if American
products do not receive preferential
treatment in their markets our military
is packed up and leaving
which some countries I did that with and
usually took a phone call and everything
was just fine
because Economic Security is National
Security I will revoke China's most
Favored Nations trade status immediately
on day one
and I will Implement a four-year plan to
phase out all Chinese Imports of
essential goods and gain total
independence from China we have to do it
we have to do
I will hold China financially
accountable for unleashing the China
virus upon the world
and I will again withdraw from the who
which stands for we hide outbreaks we
hide the United States was paying
I think this is important because again
it's so much Common Sense involved the
United States was paying the World
Health Organization
450 million dollars a year now in terms
of money and the kind of trillions and
trillions we're talking about not that
much but it's still 450 million dollars
a year
and I took them out that's what it was
the price was 450 and that's for 350
million people China was paying 39
million dollars a year
for 1.4 billion people
it doesn't sound too right and they had
Total Control by the way we had no
control they literally own it when I
withdrew from the who they offered me to
stay in please don't leave please please
please
for what China pays they said we'll
bring it down to 39 million
I was actually close to doing this deal
if you want to know the truth but I
would have had it you would have been
angry at me I said I don't have I don't
want to have CPAC angry at me
but I might have gone back in but I
could have done it for 39 I could have
probably done it for less than that
but
now Biden has gone back
for the full price of 450 million
dollars now only has to do is read the
newspapers they were begging me to come
back in for 39 million so why would you
pay
450 million dollars do you understand
that Gordon you understand how crazy so
China's in for 39 they're saying you're
right it's unfair it's unfair
we will do it for 39 we will take you
back the headband you know who that is
we will take you back then I started to
say actually it should be much less it
should be like five or six million right
but I didn't want to go there we will
take you back for 39 million you're
right president
I said well we'll think about it we'll
see what happens but the offer will
remain open right yes sir yes sir yes
sir they went back in for the original
amount it's so sad and we have no
control by the way China controls
who so that's what it does who is
totally controlled by China we could
have saved 400 million dollars a year
it's a lot of money and now they're
asking for even more dictatorial power
and more and more and more of our money
but they're getting nothing more from
China when we're dealing with the Biden
Administration it seems that every
single day ladies and gentlemen we have
breached 90 minutes of trump speaking we
have learned nothing other than he is
really out of his mind and his followers
are arguably even worse off and
everybody else
wants it to be closed it's April fools
we want an open border that's April
Fools
we want voter ID
they don't want voter ID who wouldn't
want voter ID 88 of the Democrats except
for the leadership because they can't
cheat with voter ID but 88 of the
Democrats want voter ID
but they don't want voter ID it's April
Fool's Day they want to take the
soldiers out of Afghanistan before we
take our people and Equipment out
but we want the soldiers
to come out last
so then they
blow it into a catastrophe the most
embarrassing event in the history of our
country
it's April Fool's Day
they want all electric cars
that don't go very far
I have a friend who bought a car he said
the car is wonderful but you know I go
for an hour and a half and I got to put
a charger and I can't find the charger
I'm going crazy
weird and also all the batteries and
everything the material comes all out of
China
we have oil and gas but we don't want
the oil and gas cars
but we want everything including
electric cars but we also want gasoline
because the cars go longer and they are
preferred by many people
[Applause]
for two and a half hours
it's April Fools
they want all electric stoves all over
the country
but we don't have the electric power for
that
folks I'm switching to induction from my
gas stove I am doing it it is it's just
so good I I lived for a few months with
an induction it's fantastic it really is
one when
those kill our Birds and
are very unreliable and are the most
expensive energy ever developed we want
oil gasoline natural gas because it's
cheaper better and much more powerful
it's April Fool's Day
under my leadership we will regain
energy Independence
that we had three years ago we were on
our way to massive energy dominance we
would have been paying off our debt
because energy is big numbers it's not
like you're selling a little product
you're selling the biggest product of
all its energy we would have been paying
off our debt we would have been the
strongest you know we were going to be
we're already bigger under my
Administration bigger than Saudi Arabia
or Russia we're going to be much bigger
than both of them combined within about
a year we would have made the kind of
money they're making times five and we
would have been paying off debt and we
would have been reducing taxes and it
would have been a beautiful thing but
they came in and they said we don't want
that
I will fight for a constitutional
amendment to impose term limits or
numbers of Congress
and I will move Heaven and Earth to
fully and finally secure our elections
all Republican Governors should
immediately go for paper ballots one day
voting and voter ID
and the problem we have is we have
Governors and some of them we like and
some of them but they're all talk think
of it they control the state
and we have a lot of Governors
they should go for that paper ballots
same-day voting you know France had 37
million people voting they voted in one
day and at 10 30 in the evening they
called the winner there were no problems
their paper ballots same-day voting
voter ID
and they only had a little melon
and we would have this too for soldiers
that are very far away were people that
are legitimately sick
okay legitimately as opposed to millions
and millions of ballots flooding the
offices they used covet remember that
Trump voted by mail a day Ton's
Republicans must
[Applause]
early votes and election day votes have
to do it
to change your thinking
because some bad things happened you
know uh we like for some reason
Republicans like to vote on Election Day
right the problem is you get there and
they have so many already started but
worse if you take a look at Kerry Lake
in Arizona where they waited and waited
don't vote now wait till Tuesday wait
till Tuesday wait till Tuesday and in
the Republican areas
a tremendous percentage of the machines
were broken and you couldn't vote and
they had lines that were a mile long for
the place Republican areas and they
couldn't vote they said come back in
seven hours but people can't do that
they have little league they have
doctors
they might love Carrie they might love
that's why boating early is great we
stand for but they can't do that
and they were standing in the hot sun
for hours and hours and then they sent
in mechanics to fix them and when the
mechanics left they were far worse
mechanics and well the problems your
catalytic converter on this voting
machine there are Judges have no courage
to do what's right they have no courage
to do whatsoever
I can tell you that was the case in 2022
where we can't get rid of drop boxes we
need them in every Church what we have
to do we have to know
500 million dollars and you know if you
contribute 5 700 dollars one dollar more
than that
to a candidate they put you in jail
500 million dollars
for all of this crap that they were
doing Shenanigans they were handing out
the money
like it was candy and that's fine but if
somebody when people are going to jail
for spending like 93 dollars too much
because it's not according to election
law and until we can eliminate ballot
harvesting we will become Masters at
pallet harvesting we have no choice
beating the Democrats at their own game
wow he's admitting it interesting
and we'll do it legally the agenda I've
laid out today will end America's
destruction but it is not enough just to
stop the forces tearing America down I
want once again to build America up we
have to build our country we don't build
anymore all we do is investigate
everybody you ever see television you
know it used to be
we'd build our military we were proud of
it would be doing all things would be
all you see on thing investigation
investigation investigation now with
that being said
you got to look at Hunter I mean how
crooked is that deal but you know it's
not something I really I'd like to not
do any I'd like to get back to building
our country and making our country great
again but it's time to start talking
about greatness for our country our
objective will be a Quantum Leap in the
American state if you think that the
speech has looped back to the beginning
he's just repeating a lot of the same
stuff now close to a hundred minutes in
on the frontier to give countless
Americans a new shot at home ownership
and the American dream it's such a
wonderful beautiful day
and I'll challenge the governors of all
50 states
all 50 states to join me in a great
beautification campaign we will rename
our schools and boulevards
not after Communists but after Great
American Patriots
like who
we will get rid of bad and ugly
buildings and return to the Magnificent
classical style of Western Civilization
we will support baby boomers
and we will support baby bonuses for a
new baby boom how does that sound that
sounds pretty I want a baby boom isn't
that like the child tax credit which
Biden wants to make permanent which
Republicans are opposed to you you got
to be I'm gonna have to punch myself in
the face our country will shine Thrive
and prosper like never before
all of this is within our reach
our reach if we have
the courage to complete the job gut the
Deep stake we claim our democracy and
banish the tyrants and marxists into
Political Exile forever they are bad for
us they want us to fail
they want our country to go down
they are sick people change only happens
if we plow fearlessly ahead and declare
with one voice that the era of woke and
weaponized government is over that
hasn't even started that is our mission
and this is the turning point and the
time for that decision
because as you've probably heard me say
before
we will not back down we will not Bend
we will not quit we will not yield
we will press forward with
push we will press forward with
Vigor we will push onward and we will
finish
what we started we started a great great
positive Revolution nobody's ever seen
anything like it before right it's
called make America great again we want
to make America great again
we will cross the finish line
we will dismantle the Deep State we will
demolish woke tyranny and we will
restore the American Republic to all of
its radiant Glory
and with God's help and your support we
will make America powerful again we want
to have a powerful country we need to
have a powerful Obama
we will make America wealthy again
we will make I thought I had gotten
Beyond this nonsense in my life that's
what we want we want strength
we will make America think of your heart
pounding
we will make America proud again
we will make America safe again not like
our streets of the Cities
which are disgraced for the entire world
to watch
and we will make America great again
thank you very much CPAC thank you thank
you very much thank you thank you
everybody thank you wow
[Music]
[Applause]
well a
102 minute speech repeating many of the
same stories two three even four times
dangerously unhinged
comically delusional
and the weaponization was right there my
friends wow wow wow at least
10 000 of you were here so I didn't have
to do it alone dear God uh the 2024
election is on folks the 2024 election
is on if you're leaving and by no means
should you leave now make sure that you
have subscribed to the YouTube channel
it's free or that you've followed on
Twitch so that you'll be notified as our
2024 coverage continues
if you are a twitch Prime subscriber
please make sure to get that free twitch
Prime subscription
um before you leave if you're an Amazon
Prime subscriber that is and remember
that today is the absolute last day to
use the coupon code CPAC trash CPAC
trash
has dumped in 75 subscriptions which is
just incredible just incredible
the coupon code CPAC trash saves you 70
percent I promised that we would open
phone lines if we got to 100 members and
we did so let's do it right now via
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord join the waiting Lobby if you
would like to check in with me about the
atrocities that we saw today
really
horrifying
hold on a second there we go really
really horrifying if you want to uh talk
to me davidpackman.com Discord join the
waiting Lobby
what an absolute horrifying horrifying
horrifying event and quite frankly much
lower energy than many of the ones that
we previously experienced
that is for damn sure
uh soon they're going to be interviewing
prompt I guess apparently
if you want to talk to me make sure you
request to speak in the Discord waiting
Lobby
another CPAC is fortunately over
fortunately over because that was really
really really really scary and bad
um they're speaking to Elise stefanic
let's listen
to northern border we hear so much about
this
border with in in your District right
now so for the
I've sounded the alarm that the impact
of what's happening on the southern
border impacts my district oh give me a
break she's absolutely the worst let's
go to Denise from Pittsburgh and get it
started I want to hear from you we are
hearing from people people's reactions
to Trump's CPAC speech live
davidpackman.com Discord
and then go to the waiting Lobby
and then request to speak I'm trying to
bring on Denise from Pittsburgh Denise
you've got to accept
my invitation
just accept it Denise and then we'll be
able to talk
oh boy
Denise from Pittsburgh welcome
it's already going going bad
it's going bad quickly let's try Shannon
from Iowa Shannon from Iowa welcome
let's see what is Hi how are you um
can you hear me yes I can okay I guess
you know I was just amazed at all of the
lunacy because
I feel like we're normal but at the end
what caught me was him grifting again
and saying if we all have God on our
side but your wallet's open we'll make
it what do you think of that comment uh
it's it's the con you know it it's the
continued grift that's all it is and
this is all a business play for Trump
not not even business it's just a
financial play
and uh it's embarrassing and it's
humiliating and really again like I said
before
it's crazy that there are millions of
people too dumb to know any better even
still because people will donate and
they're gonna fall for it and it's uh
you know at some point a fool in their
money will be parted you know what I
mean Shannon I I do I mean I wonder how
many of them are got the free hat and
coin yeah right next there was a
beautiful there was an incredible deal
where you could get a coin from Newsmax
if you if you called in while Trump was
speaking how many did you get Shannon oh
well I got as many as I could too yeah
um I I just can't I
I'm just speechless and I'm not a
speechless kind of person it really is I
mean it is be it is beyond words it
really is but listen I'm glad that I
hope you'll be you'll be along for the
ride into 24 at least so I'm not by
myself here hey I'm not going anywhere I
am right here with you David thank you
so much Shannon from Iowa always great
to hear from you today is the last day
you can use the coupon code CPAC trash
to get a to get a membership on my
website Zachary Knott has just used the
code and his new member 103 today just
while we'll take we're taking calls I
will remind you if we get to 250 members
Monday's show I will do with half a
mustache and then we will say goodbye to
the mustache after that okay that's
what's on the table now at 250 I will do
the Monday show with half of a mustache
and then it goes let's go next to Jordan
from North Carolina Jordan from North
Carolina what's on your mind today
David
oh you got me
I gotcha really good
um I was watching this and I'm like
wasn't Nikki Haley
yesterday or something and she was
saying something like
the Republican party needs to move on
from the old leadership to the younger
generation like yeah isn't it kind of
embarrassing that he like shows up after
this and he's there to kind of grift and
to say like he's still relevant
meanwhile like basically everyone else
is like it's time to move on yeah we
need new people it's just really but
Trump's winning every primary poll and
he almost certainly can win the
nomination that's the that's the crazy
thing about it it's all very incongruous
kill me that's terrible yeah
at North Carolina listen your state is
going to be a factor your state is
increasingly an interesting one so I
hope I mean you're you're voting of
course I'm sure
of course and I actually spoke to you
election night 2020. wow um it was
looking scary in North Carolina I think
we went red unfortunately yeah um but
yeah crazy times all right my friend
great to hear from you all right man
take care all right there there it goes
Jordan from North Carolina Texas bear
claw has just signed up via twitch Prime
which I can't tell you how much I
appreciate we are at 104 and thanks to
Terry schweren we are at 105 at 2 50.
Monday's show I will do with half of my
mustache let's go next to Janice from
Texas Janice welcome what what did you
think what's on your mind today
uh oh
Janice from Texas please accept my
invitation and then I will be able to
hear you
hey how are you
doing great how are you I'm doing well
fantastic I'm a little surprised that I
was chosen this is so exciting you know
I'm surprised too to be honest
um I watch your show so often and I mean
I can't tell you how much I look forward
to just laughing along with the things
that you make fun of especially
yesterday I was quiet literally in tears
with Ben Carson's
um music getting played over but oh my
God for people who miss that yeah when
Ben Carson spoke at CPAC they were
playing him off like they were playing
music to get him to end for almost two
full minutes
correct me if I'm wrong Janice he was
almost speaking more and more slowly as
the music played it I I he wasn't quite
picking up on it it was almost as if he
was doing it uh in spite of the music
but
um I wanted to add also that my name is
pronounced Janiece and no big deal you
are actually the first person who
pronounced my name correctly a year ago
when I first signed on you made a lot AI
of announcement and I was just shocked I
was you're seeing that un unprompted
just by seeing the spelling I pronounced
it Janiece yeah you said Janiece Cotto
and I was I was shocked because that
doesn't even make sense to me because I
there's no reason why I would assume
that's the pronunciation that's right
Puerto Rico so I feel like when my
parents gave me the name Janice it was
meant to be spelled or said that way
anyways your Spanish show has given my
mom something to watch so thank you in
addition to that oh that's great yeah
and one note you know I know a lot of
people were hoping I would be doing the
dubbing on the Spanish Channel but like
I just I quite literally don't have the
time in the day but we just summed out
she was bummed out we took everybody's
feedback saying that the dubbing needs
to be a little higher energy and we gave
it to the dubbing team and I think the
most recent handful of Clips are much
higher energy
definitely has a crush on you I gave her
a little piece of when you did a little
bit in Spanish and she was just she she
has the biggest crush on you so thank
you for having her lean a little left
will Denise please say hi to your mom
for me I will thanks David all right
there goes Janice from Texas with an
absolutely perfect pronunciation we
haven't heard from Val from
Massachusetts
I feel like it's been years Val has it
well welcome
uh-oh Val
hello hey are you on Val
I'm on I can't believe I got in welcome
it's been at least a year since we've
spoken right it has been quite a bit
well you're coming through perfectly on
on the little one thank you
congratulations and uh hopefully you're
getting a decent amount of sleep these
days yeah the baby basically sleeps 7 30
to 6 30 at this point which really isn't
bad you know wow no that's really really
good yep and no Benadryl involved
believe it or not
unbelievable yeah thanks for the
coverage as always thank you
um
I was wondering if I'm I was in the
Northampton area
recently uh if you could recommend a
good place I don't know if I'm allowed
to mention the names of uh
good places that are you know
restaurants yeah
am I allowed to do that sure go ahead
okay I just don't want to say anything
you know
inappropriate uh I I was thinking of you
because of it being your old stomping
ground area right the show was you know
15 years ago the David packman show
started in Northampton Massachusetts
yeah I was at uh fitzwilly's actually
okay
have you have you ever been there you
know I have and uh unfortunately about
10 years ago this has nothing to do with
the restaurant but someone who didn't
like my politics confronted me at Fitz
Willy's and I said Marjorie Taylor green
doesn't like it when people do it no
that was before the Marjorie Taylor
green era but I have been there and I
was uh someone came up to me and said
they don't like my politics this was
about a decade ago
oh wow so that kind of soured The
Experience yeah but I took it like a big
boy no tears or anything
yeah no cheers well that's good yeah
all right well I just wanted to say hey
you know keep up the great work I
appreciate that very much there is Val
from Massachusetts always great to hear
from you thanks to danibu for the twitch
Prime subscription number 106 tonight
also big thanks to Blake Daniel signing
up at joinpakman.com number 107. let's
listen to just a little bit of this
unhinged interview that Trump is giving
right now they certainly had the power
to send it back because right after
everything was over and they all said
they didn't have it and I said well our
vice president isn't supposed to be a
conveyor belt if they find something
wrong all right I'd rather talk to you
guys quite frankly I think we heard
enough of trump for today let's go to
Nathaniel from London where I will soon
be no oh no that's not like Long Beach
sorry I'm not going to soon be in Long
Beach but still Nathaniel from Long
Beach welcome to the live stream if you
unmute yourself we'll be able to uh to
hear you
and people asking for the coupon code it
is CPAC trash CPAC trash it's quite
literally on the screen right above me
uh thanks to thezerkek
for the twitch Prime subscription your
number 108 if Nathaniel can unmute
himself we'll be able to hear him
Nathaniel last chance
all right and he couldn't do it he
couldn't do it let's go next to Tamisha
from New York City always great to hear
from Tamisha Tamisha welcome great to
talk to you again
can you hear me I can hear you perfectly
hi um I lost my voice a little bit but
I'm gonna try it's not covet is it
what happened it's it's not covered that
caused you to lose your voice no no I
had covet around Christmas and me too I
did not get really that sick okay I got
quite ill but I just had I guess a cold
all right yeah it could be like a
laryngitis or something
exactly okay well welcome
um I
um I wanted to talk about um Scott
is that his name yeah the Dilbert
creator of course yes he he did a tweet
I don't know if it was yesterday or
today saying that um that his canceling
is political right because
um he's he's was canceled by white
liberals but black liberals want to have
conversation with him and white
conservatives or conservatives don't
care at all
yes I thought I heard I thought I saw he
blocked me years ago as I know you know
um but what I saw I think that he said
was something like
no no conservatives nor black people
think what he said was racist or
something like that
yeah exactly well I mean I
always jump the racism bandwagon even
though I also say that if something's
racist it should be able to we should be
able to call it out and absolutely you
know stand up against it yeah but
um what he said a lot he said a lot of
problematic things yes I mean I think he
deserves a conversation about it but
what he said was problematically saying
that black people are
um what I hate black people that they're
that black people are a hate group
yeah black people are a hate group we
should have um stay away from them and
then there's no helping them or no
fixing them yeah yeah
I find those three things those three
statements alone to be problematic yes
so do I I think I I agree with you there
but my main point question was
um I responded to the tweet and I said
um why is it that white people can cry
or call out racism and not be called a
victim but if a black person calls out
racism they're called a victim yeah well
it's just it's not unique just to that
it's with everything it's just this
insane projection where it's like oh the
left cancels people actually the right
cancels people oh you know we we've
talked about all the left wants to steal
an election actually the right tried to
steal an election it's just the
projection that we've come to know and
and be unfortunately to expect at this
point
yeah projection hypocrisy a lot of
problematic stuff going on I'll say yeah
but good for you for uh responding I
wish I could respond to some of his
tweets but he blocked me you know
it's frustrating because then I got
called a racist myself I got called I
got told to shut the f up I mean I got I
got a lot of pushback and most of it was
from conservatives of course yeah not a
surprise not a surprise but listen um
this is the free market of ideas Scott
Adams was able to say whatever he wanted
to say and everybody else was able to
respond with whatever speech they wanted
to respond with newspapers are able to
decide for themselves with no government
coercion do they want to carry Dilbert
or don't they want to carry Dilbert and
many of them don't want to carry Dilbert
any longer and that's their right
yeah well you can't sell that to people
because then they'll say that it's a
conspiracy or it's
um the left that controls the media it's
always they always have an answer so of
course I mean I of course understand
your what you're saying and I agree but
um I'm just telling you what other
people will say you're completely right
they're already saying that stuff it's
uh it's to be expected
but anyway hope everything's good your
daughter's eating good well still oh my
goodness she is on fire we're having to
uh up the the food bowls because she's
just uh she's accepting all food and
extremely hungry all the time
oh that's funny because I was when you
told me the story about the eating the
bones I think of my son he's 10. but he
when he eats chicken or pork chops or
anything like that he eats cleans the
bone right off
yes she's obsessed with me I mean when
we we've actually had to put a pause on
the steak which we weren't doing
frequently anyway because she would
start sobbing when the steak was gone it
was just too triggering when when the
steak steak and and chicken seem to be
and banana anything banana based where
just sobbing with tears in her eyes when
it ends so we're putting a pause on it
it's too triggering for her oh wow yeah
yeah her appetite was insatiated it
really is it really is Tamisha always
great to hear from you you too have a
good one all right Tamisha from New York
City
thanks to Safaree for the twitch Prime
subscription your number 109 today also
thanks to Tammy Purdy signing up at
joinpakman.com today is the last day for
the coupon code CPAC trash we are taking
calls from people
in the audience just people will go next
to Austin from Indiana Austin welcome
what's on your mind today
Austin you gotta unmute yeah there you
are hey thank you David pleasure so I
was wondering uh which covet origin
Theory do you lean towards and has the
recent news about the FBI and the Boe
impacted your stance at all okay
beautiful question so listen uh I want
to know the truth about where covid came
from and I don't want anything to get in
the way of that and whatever the truth
is whatever the truth is
I want to know and that is what I'm
going to go with all of that being said
I'm not hugely convinced by the
department of energies admittedly low
confidence assessment when we have other
high confidence assessments but I think
in order of likelihood the origins or
oranges of covid would be
uh made a jump from animal to human in a
wet Market
accidentally escaped the lab bio weapon
would be third that's that's my order at
this point in time
all right thank you for that all right
Austin from Indiana great to hear from
you Vicky hurts just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member 111
also want to say thanks to New Hampshire
fog who just signed up via twitch Prime
and his new member number 112. we are uh
on the table is that if we get to 250
members tonight I'll shave half my
mustache and do the Monday show that way
with no explanation some people like it
some people don't let's go next to
Caesar from Florida Caesar welcome to
the stream what's on your mind today
Caesar from Florida please select the
correct audio device and then let me
know what's on your mind today
and last chance Caesar from Florida
please
you there yes I can hear you now awesome
thank you
um being a Floridian I'm constantly
having to worry about this contest and I
was wondering your opinion on some of
the latest things he's been pushing here
well I think it's um a
pseudo-authoritarian nonsense he's
claiming credit for a great state in
Florida and listen I love Florida as
much as the next guy I was just there I
would gladly spend two to three months
out of the year in Florida to get out of
the cold weather of the north the food
scene in in Miami and in Broward it's
all fantastic but Florida is a very
mediocre state in most metrics right in
the middle on infrastructure right in
the middle on crime you know all ranked
between 22nd and 28th not terrible but
not very good and the things DeSantis
has been taking credit for like you know
the don't say gay Bill and taking
control of Disney because it went woke
and banning CRT which wasn't being
taught in school so it's all scary
virtue signaling which if he runs for
president he will use to Puff himself up
oh yeah lately he's been uh pushing a
registration for bloggers oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and the dissolving of the
democratic party in Florida yeah now to
be fair was he pushing the dissolving of
the Democratic Party Republicans
this whole registration of bloggers
thing same seems wild and and I guess
Dave Rubin will have to register we're
not exactly Freedom you know
well then you could push that to
journalism and then because they're just
going to take from one step to the hop
to the other one and next you know they
have to talk to everyone 100 yeah no
DeSantis is a scary guy he's probably
just as nuts as Trump but much less
incompetent well he's learned from Trump
a lot uh how the courts are slow so he
gets to do what he wants like all this
he's basically pointing people that are
elected but just not by firing them by
suspending them long enough knowing that
by time the course take over their terms
will actually be over and it won't
matter yep 100 he's a dangerous guy and
let's see if he announces he's running
you know yeah Cesar what part of Florida
are you from uh Central in Orlando area
okay yeah I've been there a bunch it's
uh it's all right you know it's not my
favorite part of the state I have to say
yeah it's it's a well at least I don't
have to worry about hurricanes as much
everyone keeps worrying my family keeps
wondering oh the Hurricane's coming and
said no it's gonna land a lot of land
you got to go through before you get
this that's absolutely I don't have to
worry about that part all right Caesar
from Florida great to hear from you
all right there he goes I want to say a
big thank you to Christopher Estrada who
just signed up at joinpakman.com coupon
code CPAC trash
saves you bigly at joinpakman.com you
can easily sign up on the website and
then I will shout you out let's talk to
uh let's talk to a couple more people if
we can right I mean why not we're here
how about
um
oh I don't know how about oh I guess
Nathaniel from long Beach's audio is
fixed so let's go with that yeah sorry
about that I couldn't unmute myself but
shout out to Nate from the uh moderator
team Rhode Island uh for fixing that for
me swiftly how are you doing today I'm
doing well
good good to hear from you so I'm
actually uh pursuing a political science
degree or I currently at the moment and
I'm kind of curious
um The Common Sense man amongst the
Young Americans is like yeah we need
somebody younger in office like
personally when I hear Joe Biden running
for office I'm not very thrilled because
I feel like I'd like somebody that would
have
um a bit more uh experience and like uh
in like and not knowledge of what the
problems we go through per se in fact
that's kind of why I hear it at the
minimum wage hasn't really been raised
from uh 725 uh federally at the federal
level because uh everyone seems to think
that but I don't know um I'm just
curious um would you have do you have
any advice on like how to pursue it or I
mean I know you're not like a career
expert or anything but like what like
what can uh what should I be like
looking towards or focus on if I'm
trying to pursue
um making politics better and and
slamming their Republican
um so I mean the Republican party if you
will but well I would would suggest just
get in start getting involved at the
local level as soon as you possibly can
whatever that means is it city council
is it working on a city council campaign
for someone else is it what you you've
got to find a way to start getting
involved and then at the same time there
is a book about the fields that are most
likely to allow for making political
impact I forget if it's 80 000 hours or
four thousand weeks there's like two
books but look them up and you'll find
it read a little bit and learn about the
careers that you may want to consider in
order to have an impact
yeah that's kind of one of my concerns
too is like what happens if like you run
and you're like Carrie Lake where you
run for somebody uh something once and
then you fail and then you're basically
really won't have a chance anymore
although I I still see her running for
sending it it's although I don't know if
she'll win or not but sometimes people
win after losing stuff I don't I don't
know I wouldn't count her out yet I mean
she has no she should she has no
business trying to be in politics but
unfortunately she has supporters and so
you know we'll see but but let's not
counter out quite yet yeah well the
three supporters that showed up to uh
the capitol to the protest against that
yeah that's that's definitely some
supporters at the very least all right
well I thank you for your time and I
appreciate your advice I'll definitely
look into the uh book uh all right
nothing Samuel from Long Beach great to
hear from you big shout out to Amy David
Amy David just signed up I mean just
this is a membership created out of thin
air is new on my website and his new
member number 114 today if you're
watching on Twitch and you have Amazon
Prime and you have not signed up
anywhere with twitch Prime yet consider
giving your Twitch Prime subscription to
the davidpackman channel it costs you
nothing and it takes a few bucks from
Jeffrey Bezos which is exciting let's go
next
to
Dan from Michigan Dan from Michigan
welcome to the stream what's on your
mind today
that much how are you today I'm doing
well
all right oh man I don't have a question
prepared what do you think
um
so I get it in my head sometimes that uh
you know upward Mobility for everyone
and the environmental impact that that
would have is just gonna just gonna ruin
everything you know I don't want to
necessarily keep everyone in poverty but
I also get this idea that as we
all kind of increase our spending power
and consuming more it's just going to
tank like the the world what do you mean
but I'm not sure I know what you mean
so you know well throughout this country
and throughout the whole world there's a
lot of people who live in poverty who
don't have much of an environmental
impact yes but
as we
you know we want everyone to have a
better lifestyle but I just don't know
how we can accomplish that without
having just an insane environmental
impact I see yes no and it is absolutely
true that as developing countries
continue to develop their carbon
emissions per capita go up dramatically
that's all true I I hate to be so uh I
don't even know what the word is but it
it you've got to regulate you it comes
down to countries regulating emissions
there's really no other way because we
know that as people get wealthier they
will consume more and they will emit
more
okay so it's kind of hard you think it's
our responsibility at the top to set the
example and then hopefully as the other
nations come up they don't uh you know
do what we're doing now they kind of do
what we should have been doing this
whole time instead I don't know of any
other way quite frankly
geez that's a downer oh well sorry
thanks for under the show big fan thank
you I really just out of curiosity are
you on a Bluetooth
ah yeah you caught me okay no problem
just checking
all right Dan from Michigan thank you
very much great to hear from you
um yeah there were two signs one is that
there was like a delay in him responding
which is typical of Bluetooth and number
two he sounded like he was talking
through an old radio uh all right
everybody that does it for today thank
you for joining me thank you for
everything it's been great hearing from
people Trump ranted for nearly two hours
it is over we will see everybody on
Monday thank you very much
foreign